war es viel zu früh ich bin exakt naja gut nicht exakt aber quasi um 10 am start
aber ich muss mal kurz gucken ob lautstärke und so alles passt
weil ich hab ja ja passt passt alles gut ich habe ein bisschen rumgestellt für letzten stream ist aber eigentlich alles passt
Exzellent so
Auf geht's ich habe jetzt schon hunger leute ich habe gerade zwei brötchen gefuttert ich könnte jetzt schmittag essen ich hab jetzt schon hunger
weil es auch nicht warum warum die irgendwie einfach nur durchgelaufen sind
oben reingeschoben brötchen und irgendwie nichts angekommen aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran ich habe letzte woche asia bestellt
und ich habe noch komplette
portion futter
also komplette portion mittagessen da und das zeug schmeckt von dem asia laden immer ganz gut deswegen will ich wahrscheinlich den kram jetzt direkt
pepo fett wegfuttern genau
immer eine erfahrung von euch mit escher functions
ich habe mich jetzt nicht wie ich drauf komme ich wusste nämlich nächste woche was programmieren
Mit also in asia functions habe ich sonst noch nie gemacht mal gucken
Werdet dankeschön morgen 13 monate was ja messe subscriptions ja
danke für den sub
und wie lief euer turnier gestern ich habe nicht reingeguckt ich habe nur dann den twitter post gesehen dass ihr heute irgendwie spielt
und ja richtig
bei the way
Weiß nicht ob ich die leute heute wieder triggern soll mit teams sounds
17 uhr geht es weiter gucke ich nachher mit
ich glaube das lasse ich so das keine teams aus
tja
ich habe mittlerweile so viele emotes
In meinem pp board
Ich habe gar keine ahnung mehr
Wo was ist, wenn ich suche?
Das ist so voll.
Und ich bin ja...
Bis heute habe ich nicht auf die Reihe gekommen,
die Suche ordentlich zu programmieren.
Das Ding hat ja eigentlich eine Suche hier oben.
Aber die funktioniert nicht.
Guck, wenn ich hier eingebe,
dann geht es kaputt.
Es fängt an zu filtern.
Und dann...
Ah ja, Moment.
Wenn ich ja, ja eingebe, geht es.
Warum geht es nicht, wenn ich...
Wenn ich den ersten Buchstaben...
What the fuck?
Also ich muss nach...
Das ist...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das ist irgendwie total...
Total broken,
was ich da gebaut habe.
Wann kommt die aktuellste Version davon auf Git?
Die aktuellste Version ist
zweieinhalb Jahre oder so alt.
Ich habe daran nichts mehr gemacht.
Die kommt nicht aufs Shit.
Übrigens,
zum Thema Shit.
Ich wollte eigentlich am Freitag
was mit der Endpunkt aufnehmen.
Hat leider nicht funktioniert.
Es wäre Premiere gewesen,
dass ich mal ein Video mit einem ehemaligen Azubi von mir aufnehme.
Läuft dein Samba-Server auf einer VM
oder direkt auf...
Ich finde das Emote nicht.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Wo ist mein Ubuntu-Emote?
Hier, also, jetzt, jetzt.
Läuft dein Samba-Server auf einer VM
oder direkt auf...
Wie hast du das bei deinem großen Server gemacht?
Das ist alles direkt auf Ubuntu drauf.
Ich habe auf meiner 2AE-Kiste,
ich habe jetzt ja die fette Kiste,
da habe ich ja downgraded.
Die gibt es ja, die ist ja nicht mehr im Einsatz.
Die hat ein bisschen viel Strom gefressen.
Ich habe es jetzt so.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen als
Container mit Docker-Compose-File laufen.
Und tatsächlich,
der Samba-Server ist ein Docker-Container,
glaube ich sogar.
Kann aber auch sein,
dass er direkt auf dem Ubuntu-Server ist.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Also, ich habe eine Mischung aus ein paar Docker-Containern
und einer VM.
Eine VM läuft noch und das ist Home Assistant,
weil es in der VM besser läuft.
Genau.
So sieht es aus.
Was ist hier los? Ich habe Hunger.
Schaust du morgen WWDC?
Könnte man eigentlich machen, ja.
Wie viel Uhr ist denn das morgen?
Ich habe mir morgen frei.
Das passt eigentlich.
Moment, Dark Reader, please, please.
Ah, yes.
Excellent, excellent.
Auf der Entwicklerkonferenz zeigt Apple
die nächsten Betriebs...
Ah, ist das schon wieder?
War da nicht erst was?
Haben wir nicht erst Tim Apple zugeguckt?
7. Juni.
Okay, morgen.
Wie viel Uhr?
Steht da irgendwie...
CST?
Uhr?
Ja, wie viel Uhr ist es denn morgen?
How to watch?
News.
Ja, 7. Juni um 19 Uhr.
Das mache ich, das schreibe ich mir gleich mal in den Kalender,
dass ich es nicht, dass ich es nicht vergesse.
Sonst, ja, ich bin jetzt...
Ich habe jetzt auch so einen Boomer-Kalender,
dass ich mir die Sache, dass ich die Sache nicht vergesse.
Also sprich, Eintrag machen...
Morgen, 7. um...
Wann ist das?
19 Uhr?
Nenne ich mal...
Attendees, Tim Apple.
Alles klar.
So, äh...
Starts...
19.00
Und dann schreibe ich jetzt einfach noch dabei,
das Ding soll mal Bescheid sagen, eine Stunde vorher.
Oder zwei Stunden vorher oder so.
Okay.
Excellent.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Habe ich jetzt dabei.
Ja, können wir morgen, können wir morgen Apple-Event gucken.
Da muss man immer aufpassen, wenn die Musik streamt,
dann muss man das gleich löschen danach.
Ach, den, den, den...
Das Wort oder direkt.
Ja.
Was wird denn vermutet?
Neue Predictions.
Tom's Guide.
Was ist denn...
Ich kenne die ganzen Seiten alle nicht.
Okay, was wird denn, was wird denn predicted?
Best iPhones right now.
Ja gut, das sagen sie ja zu allem.
M2-Chip ist nicht erst der M1 rausgekommen?
Stimmt, was ist eigentlich bei der Geschichte rausgekommen
mit Epic Games und Apple Store?
Habe ich gar nicht verfolgt.
Der M1 ist ein Jahr alt, okay.
Äh, ja, okay, das ist so ein typischer Newsartikel.
Wir wissen überhaupt gar nichts.
Ah ja, jetzt, okay, so, Predictions.
Predictions.
Big Sur.
Ja, warten wir es mal ab.
Wir wissen eh wieder, wie ein Apple-Event läuft.
Äh, die werden uns 30 Milliarden mal erzählen, dass das so amazing, so easy, thrilling, hyped, äh, was auch immer.
Huge.
Massive.
Was auch immer ist.
Und sie werden coole Trailer machen.
Das können sie bei Apple ja immer gut.
Also diese kleinen Clips, das sind ja gar keine Trailer.
Wie nennt man das denn?
Diese, diese kleinen Werbeintros, die sie da immer haben.
Die sind, die können die echt ganz gut.
Aber ansonsten wird es wahrscheinlich total unspektakulär sein.
So wie die letzten Apple-Events auch.
Ich meine, beim letzten Apple-Event war mein persönliches Highlight, das sagt schon alles,
ein komischer Bluetooth-Knopf.
Ja.
Und das war noch nicht mal Highlight in dem Sinne, dass ich es mir jetzt kaufen werde oder so.
BF6 Leaks wieder.
Oh, oh, da muss ich aufpassen, wenn ich BF6 Leaks zeige, weil ich weiß ja schon, wie Battlefield 6 aussieht.
Da muss ich aufpassen, dass ich nix, nix verrate.
Keck, wait, Alter.
Da muss ich, muss ich, äh, einfach Klappe halten und Level Cap und Stribane lassen.
Ich tue einfach so, als weiß ich es nicht.
Ich ignoriere einfach alles.
Ich ignoriere einfach alles und sag nix, ja.
Ich find's aber witzig.
Ich find's aber witzig, wenn man weiß, wie das Game aussieht.
Ob man die ganzen Leak-Gerüchte, die ganzen Leak-Gerüchte auf Reddit, auf Red-, auf Reddit sieht,
wo es dann auf der einen Seite totale Schwachsinns-Bilder gibt, wo die Leute sagen,
oh nee, kann ja überhaupt nicht sein.
Und dann gibt's Bilder, wo ich halt von denen weiß, dass sie echt sind.
Und dann schreiben die Leute dabei, oh nein, es muss Fake sein.
Ich find's eigentlich ganz lustig.
Ja, leider, leider kann, darf ich euch absolut gar nix erzählen über das Game.
RIP.
Hast du auch so eine angebliche Nachricht von Battlefield auf Twitter bekommen?
Ja, ja.
Woher weißt du, wie Battlefield 6 aussieht?
Äh, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich überhaupt eine Sache sagen darf, warum ich's weiß.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es.
Ich weiß nicht, was, ich hab's mir nicht im Detail durchgelesen, was ich unterschrieben hab, was ich nicht sagen darf.
Darf ich überhaupt sagen, dass ich was unterschrieben hab?
Weil ich nicht sagen darf.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Illuminati, ja.
Deswegen find ich's auch immer lustig, wenn hier so Leute wie, keine Ahnung, Levelcap oder, oder...
Moment, wo hab ich, ich hab doch hier so ein Battlefield-Video aufgemacht.
Ja.
Ähm, deswegen find ich's auch immer lustig, wenn gerade solche Leute da, äh, immer, immer so tun, so nach dem Motto,
oh, konfirm, Fragezeichen, wie, wie, was.
Die wissen's ganz genau, was Sache ist.
Du hast doch gesagt, dass du angeschrieben hast,
bevor du es unterschrieben hast.
Ja, dann.
Ja, dann, wenn ich's schon mal erzählt hab.
Ist ja auch egal.
Ich darf zumindest keine Details erzählen.
Ähm.
Aber ich werd zum Reveal ein Video mit dem Lost hochladen.
So, das, das kann ich schon verraten.
Das muss ich mir nur noch mal absegnen lassen, ob ich da nicht Dinge erzähl, die ich nicht erzählen darf.
Also, mal gucken.
Mal schauen, mal schauen.
Das dauert ja nicht mehr lang, ne?
Ist ja bald.
Battlefield 6 Reveal.
Genau, 9.
Das können wir uns zusammen angucken übrigens.
Wann ist das denn?
Wann ist denn der 9.?
Der 9. ist Mittwoch.
Okay.
Das können wir uns, das können wir machen.
Das können wir machen.
Dann, dann, ähm.
Dann werde ich mir im Vorfeld noch mal genau erklären lassen, was ich sagen darf und was nicht.
Und dann machen wir am 9. nachmittags einen Stream,
wo ich dann ein bisschen mehr erzähle zu dem, zu dem Game.
Weil ich, wie gesagt, also ich, ich weiß noch einiges mehr über das Game als das, was es im, im, dann wahrscheinlich da zu sehen gibt.
Also, ja.
Das können wir machen dann am 9.
Vorher geht das nicht.
Sieht man bei dir Gameplay im Video?
Das weiß ich nur nicht.
Kein Kommentar.
Da kann man ja quasi auf Twitch hier einen Streamplan erstellen.
Ich könnte eigentlich mit dem Lost streamen.
Mittwoch, 19 Uhr.
Musst du ihn mal fragen.
Das wäre eigentlich ganz gut.
Hm.
Traust du optimistisch zu Battlefield 6?
Ja.
Nee, nee, 16 Uhr.
16 Uhr, nicht 19 Uhr.
16 Uhr ist es, ne?
Am Ende ist alles ein riesiger Bait von Max.
Ja, kann sein.
Kann sein.
Stream, Kalender.
Hm.
Wie viele Fraktionen wird es geben?
Das sage ich nichts zu.
Cake Wait, Alter.
Ich halte mich an sowas.
Vielleicht soll das andere immer irgendwelche Leaks raushauen und heimlich Sachen aufnehmen und sonst was.
So, also.
Wenn du Android nutzen würdest, was für ein Handy würdest du nehmen?
Wahrscheinlich ein offizielles Google.
Was kosten die Dinger?
Wie kosten...
Was heißt denn die...
Früher hießen die...
Die heißen Pixel jetzt, ne?
Früher hießen die ja anders.
Früher hießen die doch, ähm...
Wie hießen die Dinger früher?
Die hatten doch früher einen...
Nexus.
Nexus, genau.
Wird es wieder eine Pixel?
Wird es wieder eine Frau mit Hakenhand geben?
Ne.
Ich glaube, das kann nicht liegen, das wird es nicht geben.
Oder, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob es das geben wird.
So, also was kostet der Kram grade?
Also ich...
Also wenn ich mir ein Android-Handy holen würde, dann wahrscheinlich ein offizielles Google-Handy,
dass der Kram auch ein bisschen länger supported wird.
Das sind aber keine Apple-Preise.
Also für Apple-Preise müsste der Kram mindestens doppelt so teuer sein.
teuer sein weißt weißt du schon was über das neue
kort nehmen ich war überrascht ehrlich gesagt dass mich gefragt hat ob ich mir
battlefield 6 angucken will weil immer ganz im ernst ich habe die letzten jahre
über jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel battle content battlefield content gebracht und
ich habe das spiel eigentlich auch zum größten die letzten zwei spiele
eigentlich auch zum größten teil geflammt also also ich hätte mich
wahrscheinlich nicht eingeladen aber okay wichtiger jonas sagt hat mir vor
zwei tagen ein oneplus 8t gekauft jetzt auf den boden gefallen rippt ja sagt
wenn man das noch fett gibt warum gibt es denn da so viele ja also ich würde
also wenn ich mir ein android handy kaufen würde dann wahrscheinlich ein
offizielles dass ich auch weiß dass ich updates krieg ich muss halt ehrlich
sagen dass ich es nicht so gut verstehe weil ich weiß dass ich es nicht so gut verstehe
sagen dass ich es nicht so gut verstehe weil ich weiß dass ich es nicht so gut verstehe ich bin schon seit ein paar jahren so auf
ich bin schon seit ein paar jahren so auf
ich bin schon seit ein paar jahren so auf apple handys hängen geblieben das liegt
apple handys hängen geblieben das liegt
apple handys hängen geblieben das liegt aber auch zum größten teil daran weil ich
aber auch zum größten teil daran weil ich
aber auch zum größten teil daran weil ich von der firma den apple handy immer
von der firma den apple handy immer
von der firma den apple handy immer gestellt kriege und ich sehe es da
gestellt kriege und ich sehe es da
gestellt kriege und ich sehe es da nicht ein noch ein eigenes handy zu
nicht ein noch ein eigenes handy zu
nicht ein noch ein eigenes handy zu kaufen wozu aber man schon als ein
kaufen wozu aber man schon als ein
Ich habe jetzt ein iPhone 11.
Das reicht mir.
Ich hatte ja vorhin ein XR.
Das XR hätte mir auch noch gereicht.
Es gibt ja kaum noch Deutsche, die Battlefield-Content machen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber das liegt ja einfach daran, weil die letzten Battlefield-Teile gesackt haben.
Hast du Infos zum neuen Half-Life 3?
Ja.
Habe ich.
Ich bin der Einzige auf der Welt, der weiß, wann Half-Life 3 rauskommt.
Half-Life 2 ist ja jetzt irgendwie Game of the Decade oder so.
Habe ich, glaube ich, irgendwo gelesen.
Oder war das schon länger her?
Naja.
Aber haben sie auch recht.
Hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch gewählt.
Wobei es gerade so 2000 bis 2010 echt viele geile Games gab.
Ja, Captain Peng ist echt so.
Also wenn ich Battlefield spiele, dann spiele ich eigentlich nur noch ein paar Runden Battlefield 3.
Und dann ist gut.
Dann reicht es mir auch schon wieder.
Half-Life.
Wenn ich zwischen den zwei auswähle.
Dann würde ich es auch schon wieder aussuchen müsste.
Genau.
Ich bin der einzige Entwickler von Half-Life 3.
Jetzt ist es raus.
Mal gucken, ob YouTube jetzt noch irgendwas Neues hat, was es uns empfiehlt.
Heute war echt nur Crap dabei in den YouTube-Empfehlungen.
Hat jemand irgendwelche guten Videos, die wir gucken müssen?
Irgendwas, was sich für den Stream eignet?
Nicht irgendwelche sinnlosen Debates?
Also YouTube hat mir heute wirklich nur Müll empfohlen.
I am wanna extend schon zwei Monate Subscription.
Ich habe übrigens die ganzen Subs nicht vorgelesen, die ich...
...gekriegt habe hier in der Zwischenzeit.
Also nicht heute, sondern zwischen den Streams.
Da waren ein paar Sachen dabei.
Der Sorex hat zum Beispiel gesubbt vor 18...
Ne, vor...
Vor...
Ne, zwischen den zwei Streams.
Genau.
Gleich für den Sub.
Dann haben wir Jan Wack.
Headknock.
Der Cheesybro ist wieder am Start.
Pongers.
Das wäre lustig.
Killerspiele.
Die Lügen der Medien.
Oh, ne.
Ne, dieses Thema kriege ich nicht.
Das ist von 2011.
Killerspiele ist...
Aber habt ihr mal gemerkt, wie schnell Killerspiele vorbei sind an Thema?
Das war ja mal...
Sagen wir mal so...
Von 2000 an bis 2015 oder so war das laufend irgendwo im Gespräch.
Und die letzten fünf Jahre gibt es einfach gar nichts mehr.
Ich glaube, das liegt zum größten Teil daran, dass Gaming jetzt einfach komplett Mainstreamt.
Mit allen seinen Vor- und Nachteilen.
Hatte nicht nur Vorteile.
Und dass viele Leute selbst spielen, die jetzt da in Positionen sind, die darüber entscheiden, was da gemacht wird und was nicht.
Also Killerspiele hat sich komplett erledigt.
Es gibt mal irgendwo wieder einer, der was erzählt.
Dieser komische Hirnforscher da ist ja da auch immer ganz, ganz vorne mit dabei.
Weiß nicht, ob es den Pfeifer noch gibt.
Aber ansonsten hat es mit Killerspielen...
Eigentlich ausgekillerspielt.
Das liegt auch an Fortnite.
Ja, das kann schon durchaus sein.
Fortnite sieht halt wirklich nicht aus wie ein Killerspiel.
Wie wäre es mit einem Video zu Crowfall?
Ich glaube nicht, dass...
Was ich bei MMOs lustig finde, hat irgendjemand...
Es gibt zwei MMOs, wo ich nicht checke, was Sache ist.
Es gibt einmal so dieses Hype-MMO, wo jetzt jeder was zu gesagt hat.
Ashes of Creation.
Wo ich eigentlich dachte, die sind done und haben jetzt ein Battle Royale gemacht und haben sich verpisst.
Aber anscheinend doch nicht.
Die sind da wohl noch dabei.
Und dann gab es ja dieses Chronicles of Elyria, die eigentlich auch gesagt haben, sie sind pleite oder so.
Und danach haben irgendwie Leute gesagt, wir verklagen dich jetzt, weil du das Geld eingesagt hast und kein Game gemacht hast.
Und jetzt entwickelt er angeblich doch wieder an dem Game.
Ich blicke legit bei aktueller MMO-Entwicklung nicht mehr durch.
Pains.
Teile deines Skills, werde Informatik-Lehrerin.
Ho.
Okay.
Machen wir das, gucken wir uns an.
Das ist nicht lang.
Oh, das war schon ein krasses Dubstep-Intro, Alter.
Und jetzt geht ja schon Pains-Champing los, Alter.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Dubstep ist auch out, oder?
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Als jeder so 2012, 11 rum Montage gemacht hat, war da überall Wupp, wupp, wupp drin.
Ja, ne?
Mittlerweile hat das keiner mehr.
Der 3D-Kick ist doch nicht am Start, ne.
Es macht auch kaum noch einer der Rude Sandstorm-Jokes und Memes.
Es ist auch vorbei.
Dubstep ist krass tot.
Glaube, fast keine Musikrichtung ist so hart gefailt wie die.
Ah.
Ich hab weder Dubstep gehört, als es angesagt war, noch jetzt.
Gut, ein paar Sachen sind natürlich auch so dem jeweiligen Zeitgeist geschuldet, ja.
Es gibt auch keine Fussel.
Es gibt auch keine Fus-Ru-Da-Collections mehr, oder Compilations mehr.
Das war ja so zu Skyrim-Zeiten, wo sie einfach dieses komische Dragonborn-Intro reingeschnitten haben
und dann sind Leute aufs Maul gefallen.
Ich muss ehrlich gestehen, ich fand das zur damaligen Zeit echt lustig.
So, was wird uns jetzt hier erzählt?
YouTube, was gibt's da so?
Alter, was ist das für MonkaS-Musik?
Also außer, dass man sie kaum hört.
So, besser.
Shingekuro, Dankeschön.
23 Monate.
Huge.
Hyper-Subscription, hab ich geklappt.
Genau, Arcadas.
But there is one day for Dragonborn.
Fus-Ru-Da.
Da, das war noch Zeit.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich glaube, ich bin der Einzige, der Skyrim nicht wirklich gespielt hat.
Also ich hab's auf Steam, aber ich hab's vielleicht, keine Ahnung, eine Stunde gespielt.
Ich bin da nie reingekommen.
Aber was ich cool finde, ist, Dings hier, hab ich jetzt angefangen.
Ohne Scheiß, ich hab jetzt, ich hab fünf, sechs Stunden hier schon den Mod gespielt.
Fand ich viel, find ich viel besser als das originale Skyrim.
Weiß ich, wahrscheinlich habt ihr das alle schon vor fünf Jahren oder so gespielt, als es rausgekommen ist.
Ich find das echt nice.
Ja, Morrowind war nice.
Morrowind hab ich gespielt, aber das war ja auch noch Boomer-Zeiten.
Das war Unreal, Unreal 1 Game, glaub ich, ne?
Morrowind.
Unreal Engine 1.
Oder Unreal 1 Engine.
Was auch immer.
Ich kann mir aber nicht merken, wie rum das heißt.
Du hast Skyrim für die Switch auch nie gespielt.
Ja, wer spielt auch Skyrim und Witcher auf der Switch?
Der Switcher.
Der Switcher in 600x400 Auflösung oder was auch immer das auf der Switch hat.
Hey Max, du hast ja Unify Access Points.
Machst du dort...
Ja, äh, äh, mein...
Ja, mach ich, mach ich.
Ja.
Ja, mach ich.
Hm.
Mein IOT WLAN hat ein eigenes WLAN.
Und das muss man auf der einen Seite einstellen am MikroTik und auf der anderen Seite einstellen am, äh, im Unify-Controller.
Ist das?
Ich dachte, Morrowind war Unreal.
Bin ich jetzt total verwirrt?
War das Game...
Da sind tatsächlich viele MMOs früher mit Game, Gamebrio oder wie man das ausspricht.
War Morrowind nicht Unreal?
Unreal?
Vielleicht bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander.
Tatsächlich.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Irgendwie habe ich im Hinterkopf, das wäre Unreal gewesen, das erste.
Äh...
Auch über verschiedene SSIDs.
Ja.
Gar kein Problem.
Ja, das ist das, was die auch für Fallout und so verwenden.
Aber es gibt relativ viele alte MMOs, die da auch...
Das war wohl früher relativ beliebt, hier der Kram.
Gibt es Half-Life auf der Switch?
Kein Schimmer.
Sorry.
Orangebox oder so gehabt.
Na gut, also schauen wir mal, was hat YouTube denn heute zu bieten?
Ich habe übrigens ein richtiges Paints-Champ-Video gefunden, Leute.
Wobei, wir gucken jetzt erstmal das Video an, was jemand im Chat geshared hat.
Teile deiner Skills.
Werde Informatik-Lehrerin.
Schreibt man das jetzt nicht?
Schreibt man jetzt nicht korrekterweise Lehrer-Sternchen-Innen- oder Doppelpunkt?
Und dann ist die Frage, ob das I groß oder klein.
Lieber nicht.
Okay.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Alter, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Das, sich bei Twitch empfohlen zu bekommen, früher bei einem Black Ops 1-Video.
Nice, dass du hier bist.
Okay, es geht nach 20 Sekunden.
Ich weiß nicht, wer das Video empfohlen hat, aber es fängt schon Paints-Champ-ig an.
Werde Informatik-Lehrer.
Was zum Teufel hat das mit Informatik-Lehrer zu tun?
Und was ist das für ein Wupp, wupp, wupp im Hintergrund?
Was genau hat das mit Informatik-Lehrer zu tun?
Außerdem, der Typ, der ist...
Der Typ ist, keine Ahnung, 16 oder so.
Der wird bestimmt kein Informatik-Lehrer.
Also, jetzt noch nicht.
What?
Okay.
Das ist bescheuert.
Vor allem, wie das einfach 14.000 Views hat und keiner hat kommentiert.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass sie das intern 5 Spilljahren mal aufgerufen haben.
Oder sogar Ads geschaltet haben auf YouTube.
Würde euch das ansprechen, Lehramt zu studieren?
Also, mich nicht.
Ich würde aber im Leben...
Auch sowieso nie Lehramt studieren.
Nein.
Klar.
Also, ich würde im Leben nicht Lehramt studieren.
Allein schon, wenn ich mir vorstellen müsste, ich müsste mich täglich mit irgendwelchen Kindern oder Jugendlichen auseinandersetzen.
Und dann nicht nur mit 1, 2, sondern auch noch mit 30 auf einmal.
Ne.
Also, ich meine, normale Leute gehen mir schon auf den Sack.
Kinder aber erst recht.
Du würdest die Kinder einfach ins Wieland tun.
Du meinst das quasi jetzt, wenn man das dann mal auf Real-Life überträgt, du würdest die dann quasi einsperren in der Klasse und abhauen.
Oder die Tür zwischen zwei Klassenräumen aufmachen und du gehst über den Flur.
Das wäre natürlich auch eine Idee.
Ein Azubi alleine raubt einem schon die Nerven.
Ne, das finde ich nicht.
Das stört mich nicht.
Azubis hatte ich auch schon viele.
War jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass die ein Jahr am Stück jeden Tag bei mir waren.
Oder so.
Aber halt ganz normal bei uns im Team.
Und das fand ich immer nice.
So, jetzt wissen wir, wie man in...
Oh, in my homeland Baden-Württemberg we say we are all sitting in one boat.
Das ist hier Oettinger Heimatland.
Was empfehlen die mir hier noch bei dem Video?
Oh, Alter, ist ja gut.
Werde eine Reli-Lehrerin.
Was ist denn eine Reli-Religion-Lehrerin?
Oder was ist eine Reli-Lehrerin?
Ist das Religion?
Ne, oder?
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Was ist Reli?
Echt?
Warum überhaupt noch Religion?
Die sollen Ethik machen und gut ist?
Das ist bestimmt genauso cringe wie das andere.
Und weiter?
Scheint ja äußerst spannend zu sein.
Man guckt den ganzen Tag sich Bücher an.
Das heißt, wenn du Religionslehrer wirst, setzt du dich auf die Erde in der Bibliothek.
Und die Mädels kommen freiwillig zu dir.
Und sagen, ah, guck mal da, du bist Religionslehrer.
Das finde ich aber nice.
Die Videos sind so schlecht, ja.
Wer hat sich das ausgedacht?
Was soll, ey, Alter, was soll uns das Video überhaupt sagen?
Was, er ist der Schüler und sie, die sind doch ungefähr gleich alt.
Oder ist das mein Boomer-Blick, der das nicht mehr erkennt?
Okay, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen plassen Schimmer, was die uns mit diesen Videos sagen wollen.
Quitsch-Level.
Hat da eigentlich einer kommentiert?
Warum hat das 30.000?
Die haben Werbezeug geschaltet auf YouTube.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das Video sich jemand sonst freiwillig anguckt.
Im Leben nicht.
Das wollen sie uns wahrscheinlich damit sagen, ja.
Komplett sinnfreies Video.
Welchen MikroTik-Router hast du?
Ich brauche einen mit 4x10 Gigabit-Ports.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Meiner hat gar keine Gigabit-Ports.
Meiner hat 6 Gigabit-Ports.
5 Kupfer, 1 S.
Aber wenn du einen brauchst, die haben jetzt einen neuen.
Sekunde, die haben einen neuen.
Nicht den.
Ach, come on.
Die MikroTik-Seite sackt.
Die haben jetzt einen neuen, habe ich gelesen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der schon raus ist.
Brauchst du wirklich einen Router?
Brauchst du wirklich Routing-Performance?
Oder brauchst du eigentlich einen Switch, der ein bisschen Layer 3 kann?
Also im Prinzip ja.
Ich weiß, ihr kennt mich.
Es gibt keine Layer 3-Switches.
Ist im Prinzip richtig.
Das ist ein Switch, der routen kann.
Ich weiß, das werden die Cisco-Leute anders sehen.
Aber für mich ist halt bei MikroTik der Unterschied zwischen,
die haben einmal Hardware, die halt eine fette CPU hat,
die ordentlich Gigabit-weise routen kann.
Oder die haben einen Switch, der ein bisschen routen kann,
aber halt nicht die CPU hat, besonders viel Traffic zu machen.
Das ist halt die Frage.
Weil die Switches sind in der Regel günstiger.
Und du kriegst mehr Ports dafür.
Ansonsten musst du einfach mal gucken.
Die hatten aber einen neuen.
Äh.
Ja, den, äh, das ist so ungefähr den, den ich hab in dem Dreh.
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall mehrfach SF...
Sowas dazu.
Der ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Das ist aber hauptsächlich ein Switch, der ein bisschen routen kann.
Der ist gut, den hab ich auch hier.
Den haben wir sogar uns im Stream schon mal angeguckt.
Ist der Chat unterhalb der Katze kaputt?
Nee.
Okay, dann brauchst du echt ein...
Der hat einen Router.
Dann musst du dir mal die Performance, die Performance-Geschichten angucken.
Von den jeweiligen Sachen.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf jetzt auch nicht.
So, also.
Was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Ach, ich wollte euch ja noch was zeigen, was richtig Pains, Pains-champig ist.
Ähm.
Warte mal.
Wo hab ich's denn?
Das da.
Nee.
Hä?
Was ist das?
Nee, das wollte ich mir...
Ach ja.
Leute.
Wisst ihr, was ich geil finde?
Ich hab doch mal gesagt, wir können IHK-Zwischenbrüche...
Prüfungen im Stream machen.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, geht nicht.
Weil die sind ja copyrighted.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass es auf YouTube Videos gibt, wo jemand die Fragen zeigt von der IHK-Prüfung.
Das heißt, dann kann ich mich jetzt rausreden mit...
Wieso?
Ich guck doch nur YouTube-Videos.
Deswegen hab ich mir das mal gepuckmarkt.
Das gucken wir uns aber nicht jetzt an.
Ich wollte euch was anderes zeigen.
Was ist das denn hier?
Das da.
Alter, dieses Video ist so hardcore cringe.
Ich will euch damit jetzt nicht belasten, ja.
Wir gucken...
Wir gucken das nicht komplett, es sei denn, ihr wollt.
Ich wollte euch nur den Ausschnitt daraus zeigen.
Weil das Video ist echt hard cringe.
Aber was ich euch zeigen wollte, ist, wenn sie anfangen zu programmieren...
Oder sollen wir das komplett gucken?
Es ist ein bisschen cringig, ja.
Aber was ich euch zeigen wollte, ist...
Let's go.
Okay.
Es ist aber Painschamp.
Das kann ich euch gleich sagen.
Ich muss mal kurz die Musik ausmachen.
Es ist...
Es ist Painschamp.
Hey, ich bin Lukas.
Ich habe noch keine Ahnung, was ich später einmal werden werde.
Das ist übrigens Lukas.
Deshalb bin ich heute bei Launix und schaue mir den Beruf des Fachinformatikers an.
Der ist so super motiviert.
Hat aber kaum Aufrufe.
Hab ich auch noch nie gesehen von ihm.
An sich ist das Video gut gemacht, ja.
Aber ich finde den Inhalt übelst cringy.
Eben als jemand, der die fiese Ausbildung gemacht hat.
Ihr müsst mal drauf achten, was bei den Monitoren dieser Firma zu sehen ist.
Wie gesagt, der richtig hardcore cringe kommt dann hier so...
So bei 2,30 oder was heißt der hardcore cringe?
Bei 2,30 kommt das, was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte.
Sagt mal, ob es laut genug ist.
By the way, was ist das eigentlich für eine Firma?
Was ist das hier eigentlich für ein Eingang?
Das sieht, das sieht aus wie irgend so ein, so ein olles, abgestandenes Einfamilienhaus oder so.
Das ist nicht von der IHK, könnte es aber sein.
Denn die sagen ja auch noch nichts.
Der darf übrigens einfach, einfach alleine in die Firma laufen, ne?
Hallo.
Hallo Lukas.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Ich will dir heute den...
...Beruf des Fachinformatikers etwas näher bringen.
Ich muss doch ein bisschen lauter machen.
Zuerst solltest du wissen, es gibt vier Spezialisierungsrichtungen vom Fachinformatiker.
Es ist übrigens top aktuell, es gibt vier Spezialisierungen.
Also sprich, nicht nur Anwendungsentwicklung, Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration, sondern auch, äh...
Data Science, oh fuck, ich kann es mir nicht merken.
Data Science, Netzwerktechnik und...
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr.
Das erste ist der Fachinformatiker für Anwendungsentwicklung.
Alter, ist das leise.
Das zweite ist der Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration.
Es gibt noch einen Fachinformatiker für Daten- und Prozessanalysen.
Ich kann es nicht lauter machen.
Wenn ich es lauter mache, fliegen euch die Ohren weg.
Wenn die wieder Musik machen.
...sowie einen für digitale Vernetzung.
Und ich sehe, du hast schon die richtigen Sachen an, denn wir gehen jetzt zum Kunden.
Los geht's.
Ja, da freuen wir uns immer drauf.
Wir gehen zum Kunden.
Super.
Deswegen habe ich die Physie-Ausbildung gemacht.
Ich bin jetzt immer...
Na, egal.
Ich halte jetzt die Klappe.
Bist du das im Video?
Natürlich.
Klar, ich zeige immer nur Videos von mir.
So Lukas, beim Kunden müssen wir jetzt die Anforderungen aufnehmen.
Deine Aufgabe?
Dabei ist es, zuzuhören und mitzuschreiben.
Deshalb überreiche ich dir jetzt...
Der Typ, ich meine ernsthaft, der Typ ist zum ersten Mal da reingekommen.
Und was soll denn er mitschreiben?
Okay, es ist gestellt.
Es ist eh gestellt, aber ich finde es ist so page-champig gemacht.
... und einen Kugelschreiber.
Gut.
Jo.
Hallo, Herr Klaus.
Hallo, Herr Hinsch.
Der Herr Klaus.
Hallo.
Übrigens auch geil, wie Sie im Hintergrund die ganze Zeit das Firmenlogo laufen.
Also, was machen die, Rechnungen, Angebote, iih, die machen, das ist quasi so ein SAP-Lite, oder was?
Ihr individuelles ERP-CRM-System, Rechnungen, Angebote, Kalkulationen, Verträge, Workflows, Büro, Personal, das ist quasi so ein SAP-Lite, oder?
Natürlich ist das extra für den Film so gemacht.
Was können wir denn für Sie tun?
Ja, Herr Hinsch, wie schon am Telefon gesagt, ich habe ein Hausmeisterservice.
Ich habe zehn Mitarbeiter, habe eine ganze Menge Kunden und ich muss ungefähr 50 Aufträge pro Woche realisieren.
Mit Excel stoße ich an die Grenzen.
50 Aufträge pro Woche, ja, das, äh, also das Problem ist, dass er mit Excel überhaupt erst angefangen hat.
Ich brauche etwas, wo meine Kunden mit den Aufträgen verknüpft werden können und den Mitarbeitern und ein Auftrag dauert in der Regel drei Tage.
Ich brauche einen automatischen Vorschlag, wenn ich ein Anfangsdatum umgesetzt habe, wann der Auftrag zu Ende sein muss.
Herr Kloss, das machen wir genau so.
By the way, das ist übrigens viel zu spezifisch, ne?
Das ist übrigens viel zu spezifisch.
Also ich habe ja mit Endkunden glücklicherweise so gut wie nie was zu tun.
Aber, ähm, also von allem dem, was ich mitbekommen habe, und auch jetzt nicht nur bei uns, sondern auch was man so hört,
ist das nicht, wie Kunden sich das vorstellen, dass der wirklich genau sagt, was Sache ist.
Den musst du da schon ein bisschen ausfragen zu.
Lukas, an der Stelle kann man kein fertiges System mehr kaufen, sondern jetzt müssen wir programmieren.
Oh, jetzt, pass auf, pass auf, Leute, jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's.
Wieso hast du jetzt mit dem Kunden gesprochen?
Ja, okay, bla bla bla, gleich, gleich.
... Prozessschema aufzeichnen, um es anschließend einem Programmierer, sprich dem Fachinformatiker, für Anwendungsentwicklung zu geben.
Allerdings darfst du jetzt gleich mal selber in diese Rolle schlüpfen.
Und dazu ziehst du dich am besten jetzt erstmal um.
Okay, mach ich.
Das heißt, Fisi braucht Anzug, oder was?
Der Programmierer nicht.
So.
Ihr müsst, ihr müsst gleich mal auf den Bildschirm von ihm gucken.
Du siehst ja schon wie ein richtiger Hacker aus.
Oh, richtig Hacker-Man.
Schon viel bequemer jetzt in dem Pullover.
Genau.
Ich werde jetzt...
Und wie sie den Typ da hinten hingesetzt haben, guckt euch mal an, wie das hier ausschaut, ne?
Da hinten hingesetzt haben, setzt euch mal hin und tut mal wichtig Programmieren.
Deinen Ausbilder Ringo vorstellen, der hat dich durch die Programmierung begleitet.
Ohne Mist, das ist kein...
Das ist ein olles Einfamilienhaus, wo sie ein paar Schreibtische reingestellt haben.
Hallo.
Hi Lukas, schön, dass du da bist.
Kannst du ruhig schon mal hin?
Pass mal, guck mal gleich auf den Bildschirm, guck mal gleich auf den Bildschirm.
Ne, das noch nicht, das noch nicht.
Und die Kunden auch...
Das nicht, was ist denn das überhaupt hier?
Was bin ich...
Was bin ich sehend?
Können wir das irgendwie höher auflösen?
Leute, was könnten das sein?
Das ist ein Browser?
Oder sowas?
Was?
Ist das ein Linux?
Ist das ein Raspberry Pi, worauf der arbeitet?
Das fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Raspberry Pi als Workstation klingt mir hardcore Paintschampig.
Da kannst du doch nichts drauf entwickeln.
So was so, du kannst schon, aber es ist bestimmt...
Was, was, was sehe ich hier?
Ich erkenne es nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, gleich, gleich kommt das Beste, gleich kommt das Beste.
Das ist ja ein Standardwunsch, da haben wir schon was vorbereitet.
Und das ist bei uns im Editor.
Und dann sind die Komponenten unter Add Component.
Und wenn wir da unter CRM gucken, haben wir eine Firmenliste.
Und dann können wir die Firmenliste komplex, genau.
Was die alles haben.
Jetzt kannst du da eine ID eingeben, bitte ohne Lernzeiten.
Das heißt, wir klicken uns irgendeinen GUI zusammen.
Und dann...
Das ist tatsächlich...
Die haben eine Raspberry Pi Workstation.
Ach du Scheiße.
So, gleich, gleich kommt das, was ich euch zeigen wollte.
Oh, ja, das GUI.
Guckt euch das GUI an.
Hahaha.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Dann würde ich doch lieber in Excel bleiben, wenn ich dieses GUI sehe, weil...
Da ist der SAP noch schöner.
Hahaha.
Da ist der SAP High Ender.
Gut, kostet auch 30 Fahrer wahrscheinlich.
Aber Moment, es wird noch besser.
Es wird noch besser.
Genau.
So.
Und das haben wir jetzt abgeschlossen.
Und da kommen wir zur Individualprogrammierung.
Das war für den Wunsch vom Kunden.
Und zwar die...
Ja.
Frist von drei Tagen, die er
standardmäßig gerne haben möchte.
Und da kann man halt mal deine Mathematikkenntnisse testen.
Quick maths.
Und genau,
dann darfst du mal ausrechnen,
wie viele Sekunden haben drei Tage?
Oder wie berechnet man drei Tage
auf Basis der Sekunden?
Okay, also eine Stunde
hat 3600 Sekunden.
Genau so weit wäre ich auch gekommen an seiner
Stelle jetzt. Das heißt, ich rechne erst mal
eine Stunde, also
3600 Sekunden. Mal 24.
Mal 20. Mal 3.
Und das dann nochmal mal 3.
Boah, huge.
Five head time.
So, hier, hier, guck mal.
Kennt das jemand? Kennt das jemand, was hier rechts ist?
Wisst ihr,
das wollte ich euch zeigen. Wisst ihr, was das rechts ist?
Kennt ihr das?
Das ist nämlich etwa der Source Code
von diesem GUI, was die gerade
programmieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob man es noch
besser sieht gleich.
Ja, gleich sieht man es noch besser.
Ja, ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Guckt euch das mal an. Kennt ihr das?
Man sieht es, man sieht es
auch sogar oben. Das hat
überhaupt nichts damit zu tun. Das ist Linux Kernel
Code. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Linux Kernel Code
dafür, das ist Hacker Typer.
Was die da offen haben.
Jetzt, hier, Leute.
Los geht's.
Er kann natürlich direkt programmieren
und dann auch Linux Kernel Code. Gar kein
Problem.
Was soll sowas eigentlich immer? Ich habe
keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich wirkt das
irgendwie cooler, wenn die Leute hier sowas
aus Hackern nennen können.
So, ich bin drin, Leute.
Gleich haben wir es.
Ah, und jetzt abschicken.
Bam, easy.
Die wollen halt keinen echten Code präsentieren. Warum eigentlich
nicht? Warum nicht? Ich meine, die sollten
noch irgendwie Teile von ihrer Anwendung
finden, die man leaken kann in einem Video.
So, ähm,
also, so
top secret kann so ein
blaues JavaScript
GUI oder was das ist ja nicht sein.
Ist das nur die Unix
Timestamp, die wir gerade berechnet haben?
Was? Was?
Das ist die Unix Timestamp?
Wusste ich auch noch nicht.
Ich würde sagen, dass die Zeit erst am
1.1.1970 begonnen hat.
Das ist richtig. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Die Zeit hat auch nicht im Jahre 0
begonnen.
Also,
zumindest nicht
nach unserer heutigen
Zeitrechnung mit vor und nach
Christus und sowas.
Ja, das gab's. Die Zeit
gibt's eigentlich schon immer.
Also zumindest, solange
es Ursache und Wirkung irgendwie gibt.
Der 10-stellige Code, der gibt mir immer
die exakte Zeit an.
Genau. Okay, und dann überprüfen wir jetzt,
ob man die Anführung... 10-stellig ist jetzt die Frage.
Sekunden oder Millisekunden?
Und du siehst,
wir haben Aufträge, wir haben Kunden.
Wenn man auf Aufträge klickt, kann man
Aufträge erstellen.
Da wird hier der 31.8. angezeigt.
Und wenn man dann mal guckt...
Welch Magie.
Der 23., drei Tage ist der 31.
Hast du also gut gemacht.
Oh, der hat überhaupt nichts gemacht.
Ich meine, okay, es ist gestellt für das Video.
Ich finde es ja in Ordnung, dass man so Sachen
für Videos stellt.
Aber das ist schon so plump in dem Fall.
Das fand ich echt painstampig.
Okay, der Chef erklärt dir das noch
ein bisschen mehr über den Beruf.
Okay, dann tschüss. Tschüssi.
Tschüssi.
Lukas, wie hat es dir denn gefallen heute?
Also mir hat es heute hier richtig viel Spaß gemacht.
Ich fand es auch sehr interessant,
einfach mal zu sehen, was so hinter einer Software steckt.
Und am meisten hat es mir natürlich gefallen,
selber mal an so einer Software zu arbeiten.
Ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Und das alles ein bisschen besser kennenzulernen.
Okay, die zwei Sachen, die du heute nicht gelernt hast...
Der Bildschirm schon, ey.
Aber so muss das sein.
Das sind die typischen IT-Admins.
Die können Computer installieren,
Software installieren, Drucker einrichten,
solche Tätigkeiten.
Und die Fachinformatiker
für digitale Vernetzung.
Das sind die Experten für Glasfaser
und Kupferkabel.
Ja.
Das hat eigentlich
mit Vernetzung jetzt relativ
wenig zu tun.
Und ich wünsche dir
auf alle Fälle viel Spaß bei deiner weiteren
Ausbildungssuche.
Also mit Vernetzung ist nicht
unbedingt gemeint, dass ich mich gut mit Glasfaser
und Kupferkabel auskenne.
Ja, und Druckereinrichten ist klar.
Und damit sage ich tschüss. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Oh, dieses Video immer so Painschamp.
Das ist echter Wahnsinn.
Am schlimmsten fand ich das mit Hackertyper.
Also die Hackertyper-Geschichte ist wirklich
richtig, richtig hardcore Painschamp in the ass gewesen.
Ach, Moment.
Steht es in den Kommentaren? Wartet mal.
Warte mal hier.
Wirklich eine tolle Idee,
einen Hackertyper zu öffnen, weißt du.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wegt das daran, dass sie nur rumklicken?
Ah, Digger, du bist legit
10 aus 10.
Was genau möchte er uns
damit sagen?
War echt so fremdschön. Ja, sag ich euch ja.
Richtig, richtig
Painschamping
haben wir da gerade betrieben.
So, was können wir uns denn jetzt
als nächstes noch geben? Hier, zeigt mal her.
Wir lassen uns
gebeten von Levelcap.
Und ich muss meine Klappe
behalten, dass ich nicht aus Versehen irgendwas leake,
was ich auch nicht sagen darf.
Ich tue einfach so, als weiß ich von nix
und reacte auf das, wie uns Levelcap
mal wieder gebetet.
Gaming, the Battlefield Season is here.
Consoles might be getting some crazy tech.
An artist claims Capcom
stole her work and much more.
Much more.
By the way, was ich halt geil finde
bei Levelcap, der Typ weiß das.
Also der weiß das
genau so
im Endeffekt, wie ich es mittlerweile auch weiß.
Und der tut die...
Ich find das so geil, wie sie immer so tun, als wüssten sie nix.
... six months of Battlefield leaks,
rumors and speculation.
Moment, haben wir das nicht schon gesehen?
Sag mal, nimmt der jedes Mal exakt die gleichen Clips?
Der Clip mit dem Boot
kommt bestimmt auch wieder.
Ja, das wissen wir.
Am 9.
Guck, jetzt kommt gleich der Clip mit dem Boot wieder.
Ja, dieses Zeug hab ich auch bekommen,
wo ich mich...
... mich gefragt habe, was genau möchte mir Battlefield damit sagen.
Guck mal, das Boot ist wieder am Start.
Der bringt immer die exakt gleichen Clips.
... the complex has been called
the second pentagon and is where
key military and government leaders,
will go during a large-scale invasion of the country.
The unscrambled text on the image
makes it sound like a war
on a larger-scale event
has wiped out people's homes.
Level-Capture-Badge ist die Tradition, ja.
Ja, das Ding hab ich auch gekriegt.
Das ist ja mittlerweile entschlüsselt,
aber juckt mich so überhaupt nicht.
... a war.
The date on the image has also led to speculation
about the game's release date,
but nothing stands out as definitive.
Shortly after the image was sent out,
screenshots supposedly showing in-game footage
of the game leaked.
It's unclear if these images are genuine or not.
They show a desert map,
Apache Helicopter and
... and VTOL airship.
Earlier this morning,
the Battlefield Twitter account
also DM'd several creators
a cryptic video message.
The video they sent me includes a few frames
that look like a stealth bomber and a skyscraper.
It contains a still image
of what looks like some sort of attack helicopter.
This might confirm the Apache Helicopter
from the leaked screenshots is actually genuine.
Now, not all Battlefield news this week
was specifically about the...
... the...
Ich hätte echt meine Probleme, darüber jetzt zu reden, drei Minuten, und das irgendwie so dastehen zu lassen und nichts Falsches zu erzählen.
Das würde ich mir nicht gerade hinkriegen.
The upcoming game, EA have appointed former Disney and Call of Duty Warzone General Manager Byron Beattie to the Battlefield franchise.
He's currently working to help release...
Wenn ein Leak richtig ist, dann blende ein Emote ein.
Nee.
... Battlefield 6 und Battlefield Mobile.
He will play a bigger role in the development of future Battlefield games.
The appointment could mean big things are in store for the franchise.
Das Einzige, was ich leaken kann, was ich weiß von Battlefield 6 ist, dass die Entwickler bei DICE immer mehr nach Wikinger ausschauen.
Aber gut, sind ja auch Schweden.
Aber da war ich diesmal echt überrascht.
Die können eins zu eins aus Vikings sein.
... worked almost exclusively on big budget live-streams.
But it's all but assumed that this year's Battlefield game will be...
Warum weiß Max mehr als wir?
Weil ich, äh, Boomer-Influencer bin.
... a live-service title of some sort.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum die mich eingeladen haben.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab die letzten zwei Battlefields nur geflamed.
... but Beattie could be spearheading a much bigger live-service effort for the future titles.
Maybe we'll be getting the Battlefield version of Warzone one day.
In our final bit of Battlefield news, the entire franchise is 75% off on Steam right now.
Aber wisst ihr, was die Kacke ist von Battlefield auf Steam?
Ähm, du kannst ja das Spiel nicht direkt launchen über Steam.
Du musst ja, also, oder korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Ähm, warst du bei D...
Nee, nee, alles online.
Ähm, die Sache ist halt, du musst trotzdem Origin starten.
Du startest Steam, startest das Game, das startet Origin, das startet Battlelog.
Das ist irgendwie Fail.
... sent off on Steam right now, DLC included.
Amazon Prime Subscribers can also get a free copy of Battlefield 4 this month.
Hast du schon das neue Technus von GameCube?
Nee, ich hab noch nie das Nexus gesehen, nee.
... any of the previous Battlefield games.
Now is a great time to pick them up.
Pretty much every title store has an active player base, especially Battlefield 4.
Let us know what you think of all this Battlefield news in the comments.
I'm very excited to see what DICE have been up to.
Battlefield 6 hat kein Battle... äh, Battlefield 4 hat kein Battlelog.
Äh...
Doch, klar hat Battlefield 4 Battlelog.
Oder? Bring ich's jetzt durcheinander?
Klar hat Battlefield 4 Battle...
Nicht mehr?
Wie hat Battlefield 4...
Wir müssen doch Battlelog haben, du kannst es doch online sogar noch auswählen.
Now that the official marketing campaign has kicked off, what are you...
Ich seh sogar online im Battlelog Leute, die Battlefield 4 spielen.
Ach, war deaktiviert.
Was hat man dann gemacht? In-Game-Browser oder was?
... expecting to see. Leave a comment with your thoughts below.
AMD dropped some big announcements during Computex.
Probably the biggest one is that their NVIDIA DLSS upscaling alternative is coming soon.
Fidelity FS Super Resolution...
Da müssen sie alle jetzt, da müssen sie...
Nvidia macht irgendwas, da müssen sie gleich hinterher.
...intelligently upscale compatible games to present something that looks close to a native resolution output while basically doubling the performance.
Ja, Moment, das muss, das geht aber nicht so einfach.
Also, ich hab mich da vor einer Weile mal ein bisschen drüber informiert.
Also, das ist jetzt nix, was man einfach einschaltet, so wie normales Anti-Aliasing.
Anti-Aliasing? Anti-Aliasing? Wie immer man es genau ausspricht.
wo du das Game einfach in der
simpelsten Variante in höhere Auflösung renderst
und dann wieder runter. Das hier
ist was, das muss explizit in die Engine
eingebaut werden. Das kann man
nicht einfach mal so dazuschalten.
Also die Chance für
alte Games, jetzt einfach
hier oder etwas ältere Games,
wo die kein Patch mehr zu rausbringen wollen,
das einfach einzuschalten, dann geht's.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so sein.
Wenn du schon nichts leaken kannst, bist du
zumindest optimistisch, was das nächste Battlefield
angeht. Ja, bin ich.
Tatsächlich.
Ich war relativ gehypt,
aber
ja, seht ihr dann am 9.
Ich habe im Lost direkt was aufgenommen,
als der Hype noch frisch war
und das können wir aber erst am 9.
hochladen dann.
Es kommt am 9. Ja, das ist kein
Leak.
Das ist ja schon bekannt.
Er muss aber sagen,
Nvidia macht halt auch
alles, was sie tun.
Nvidia macht einiges, dass die Leute bei Nvidia hängenbleiben.
Beispielsweise diese
Nvidia Reflex-Geschichte,
ihre DLSS-Geschichte,
Nvidia
Voice-Sachen.
Also die haben vieles
zusätzlich in ihrem Ökosystem
oder auch Shadowplay, wo AMD
versucht, auch was in der Richtung zu machen,
aber es meistens nicht ganz so polished ist.
Also Nvidia
tut da einiges, für das die Leute nicht von
Nvidia-Grafikkarten wegkommen.
Es geht um Entwickler, um FSR zu unterstützen
und es scheint sehr wahrscheinlich, dass manche
es machen werden.
Machen wir heute mal wieder den Wahl-O-Mat
wegen der Wahl in Sachsen-Anhalt.
Vielleicht, wenn wir am Ende noch Zeit haben.
Ich kann das schon mal aufmachen,
aber wenn schon ganz am Ende.
Aber ich bin ja nicht
in Sachsen-Anhalt.
Irgendwo sind wir stehen geblieben.
Ah.
Also Hardware ist immer eine Balance
zwischen Leistung und Qualität.
Wenn sie ein Plugin hinzufügen können,
das automatisch die FPS-Gruppe mit dem FPS-Gruppen
ohne irgendwelche bedeutenden Nachteile,
dann scheint es wie ein No-Brainer,
FSR zu implementieren.
AMD startet FSR am 22.
mit ein paar unterstützten Titeln.
Bungie arbeitet an,
Destiny 2 zu sortieren.
Der Witz ist ja, es bringt ja noch nicht mal was,
wenn man heutzutage sagt, hey, das ist die richtige
Grafikkarte für mich, die will ich mir holen,
weil man bekommt sie eh nicht.
Das ist ja das Problem aktuell.
Was macht, geht eigentlich der Preis-Champ noch?
Leute, ich mach die 3080 Ti rein,
sobald der Crawler die 3080 Ti kann.
... PC-Performance.
... Issues.
Since its latest expansion dropped,
the game has run worse than it did at launch.
Destiny juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
That's likely due in part to the developers
increasing fidelity and complexity
to in-game assets with the update.
They recently launched an optimization patch
that should claw back some of the lost performance
but expect more updates in the future
as the developers continue to optimize the game.
Destiny juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
... developers are working on an important fix
for the game, enabling DLSS...
Die Warzone-Devs,
wenn die irgendwas fixen,
sind 20 andere Sachen kaputt.
Also ich verfolg's,
ich spiel ja Warzone nicht mehr aktiv,
ich verfolg's nur am Rande.
Also das, was Ravensoft da abliefert,
ist ja wirklich an Lächerlichkeit kaum noch zu überbieten.
Es gibt Skins, die unsichtbar sind.
Es gibt die krassesten Balancing-Scheiße ever,
die man je gesehen hat.
Es sind, glaube ich,
Stun-Granaten wieder kaputt seit einer Woche oder so.
Es ist komplett im Arsch, was die treiben.
Ich verfolg's nur noch so auf Reddit und nebenbei.
Ich kann mir das Game nicht geben.
Würdest du den GPU,
den GPU-Markt irgendwie regulieren,
wenn du könntest schlechter Markt finden?
Nö.
Würdest du den GPU-Markt nicht regulieren?
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass Nvidia und AMD
da ein eigenes Interesse dran haben,
dass Grafikkarten für Games und Gamer
wieder verfügbarer werden.
Weil es kann denen letztendlich nicht egal sein,
ob es Miner oder Gamer kaufen.
Die machen ihr ganzes Geld mit,
ihr ganze Promotion,
alles drumherum,
Gaming und Gaming-Ökosystem.
Das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte,
ist, dass die normale Edition,
also die wollen sich das Geschäft mit Minerkarten
wahrscheinlich auch nicht entgehen lassen,
was ich mir vorstellen könnte,
dass die eben Grafikkarten rausbringen,
für Mining geeignet und welche nicht für Mining geeignet.
... kürzlich Waffenoptik zu brechen,
die sie unklar machen.
YouTuber JayGod hat das Problem in einem vergangenen Video dokumentiert.
Die Entwickler haben schnell gesagt,
dass der Faktor im Prozess war,
aber sie haben noch keine Updates auf das Problem veröffentlicht,
die sie bis dahin nicht veröffentlicht haben.
Für den Moment ist euer bestes Wettbewerb,
DLSS vollständig abzuschalten.
Ubisoft hat veröffentlicht,
dass Far Cry 6 einen 3-Person-Gameplay-Modus eröffnen wird.
Letzte Woche wurde das Gameplay mit einer Reveal-Cutscene
in 3-Person-Mode veröffentlicht,
was für die Franchise ein 1-Person-Modus sein wird.
Das Spiel wird mit vollem Charakter-Customisieren veröffentlicht.
Es ist toll zu sehen, dass es optional ist,
denn ich bin sicher,
dass viele Fans der Franchise
ihre traditionelle 1-Person-Perspektive liefern.
Also klingt es wie die Wahl für unsere 1-Person-Perspektive...
Also wisst ihr, was ich,
wisst ihr, was ich preferen würde bei Far Cry,
wenn da ein gutes Gameboy rauskommt?
Ob das jetzt 3rd-Person oder 1st-Person ist...
Ich mein, 1st-Person gehört irgendwie mit dabei,
aber ob das jetzt noch ein 3rd-Person hat oder nicht,
who cares?
... ist a good idea.
Modders are going buckwild with Half- Alyx.
A new mod is now available that adds multiplayer
to Valve's groundbreaking single-player VR title.
You and a friend can play through the story together.
You appear as floating aliens
bringing robots to each other,
but experience the game normally otherwise.
It's a fun-looking experience.
It'll be exciting to see how the community
from Valve's games builds up.
The developers released it as an open-source project,
so anyone can download it
and modify it.
Nee, den Partner-Mod hab ich nicht ausprobiert.
... claims Capcom stole her photos
for multiple Resident Evil and Devil May Cry games.
Anzeige ist falsch.
Her photographs of real-world locations
were used throughout Capcom's titles
as texture and model assets.
She says the game stole her images
from a book that she published called Surfaces in 1996.
It included a CD of images from the book
that artists, architects and designers
could use as inspiration for their work.
The photos are all copyrighted,
so using them directly is a big problem.
The examples that Judy provided
as part of her court filing against Capcom
clearly show Capcom directly using those images.
Some of the assets even have the original file name
from her book's CD.
It's tough to say how the court will rule,
because copyright law is very complex,
though it seems unlikely that they'll rule
in Capcom's favor.
Playerunknown's Battlegrounds
has a new experimental mode
called Racing Mode, and well...
Hat da...
Meine Frage an die PUBG-Spieler.
Hat da nach irgendjemand gefragt?
Wie ist eigentlich so der Stand von PUBG?
Ist das mittlerweile mal halbwegs fertig?
Also sprich, läuft das halbwegs gut?
Oder...
...
Sind die Spieler zufrieden damit?
Dead.
Spiel für PUBG, die Koreaner mögen das immer noch.
It's basically Mario Kart Battle Royale Edition.
Players race across Miramar in a selection of vehicles.
Each one includes a special weapon
that you can use to blow up other players.
The course is one-way and has various checkpoints
that you'll respawn at if you die.
There's also boost and ammo-cruise
that you can ram through for speed boost
or to replenish your weapons and munition.
Racing Mode will be available until the 14th.
Before we get to our final story, thanks for tuning in.
Be sure you subscribe to catch our complete trailer breakdown
and the Battlefield reveal.
We'll be launching it as soon as possible
after the trailer goes live on Wednesday.
By the way, chat, niemals Games vorbestellen.
Lohnt sich einfach null in der heutigen Zeit.
... will have a big announcement soon.
The game is being developed using the GZ Doom engine
and so far it looks like a ton of fun.
It's the latest in a new wave of retro FPS titles
that utilize or emulate old game engines
while offering modern gameplay mechanics and visuals.
Sulaco is getting a demo soon that you can get access to
by subscribing to the developer's Patreon account.
Hopefully, open access isn't too far behind.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always, guys, thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you next time. This is LevelCap signing off.
In the next episode...
This is the lock picking lawyer
and every once in a while I come across a lock like this
Das ist die Musik jetzt einfach an.
Die Musik dabei, lol.
Kurz Musik ausmachen.
Die coolste Waffe in der Halo-Reihe.
Geht ein bisschen zu leise.
So, das war die ganze Zeit.
Ich kann mir Halo-Waffennamen einfach nicht merken.
Ich bin da zu nah.
nur bin ich für also dieses normale halo alien schussding wobei diese animation noch ein ganz
anderes problem aufwirft oder er auswürfen diesen design vermutlich den schädel einschlagen würdest
dass das magazin einfach so zur seite raus mag also etwas logischer erscheinen aber jetzt rate
mal was cooler aussieht naja wenn es weg fliegt reden wir über persönlichkeit in waffen animationen
nachlade animationen oder first person animationen an sich sind eigentlich mittel zum zweck irgendwann
kam jemand auf die idee dass ein first person spiel sichtbare hände haben sollte anschließend
aber noch eine waffe dazu gepackt später kam dann das nachladen der
zu was irgendeine form visuelles feedback haben musste anstatt einer fortschrittsleiste und ein
paar jahrzehnte voller entwicklung später sind wir nun da angekommen wo wir heute sind bei komplex ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich finde heute ist es fast schon ein bisschen übertrieben es gibt ja diese
vergleichs videos call of duty in game nachlade animationen in echt was ich weiß nicht ob ihr die
kennt
in real life ja das da meine ich es sieht halt echt aus wie in dem game ich finde teilweise ist
ein bisschen übertrieben in den in den games mittlerweile schon was sie da machen ich meine
du hast dann fünf verschiedene dinge an reloads dann hast du irgendwie wenn du gerade am sliden
bist aber fünf verschiedene reloads und sonst was naja ich meine es schadet auf jeden fall nichts
olino sagt hey max das ist so geil ich habe dich über sieben jahre oder so seit drei jahren seit
drei monaten auf youtube wiederentdeckt und jetzt sogar im stream preis ja es gibt demnächst also es
gibt spätestens zu battlefield release gibt es neues video ich meine wie gesagt das ist halt
das ist halt real life und kein game wenn man das nicht weiß könnte man durchaus denken es ist aus
dem kot man die kleinen bewegung vom arm und jetzt dieses bisschen gewackele und so geben das schon
noch preis dass es ein echtes video ist aber es könnte schon aus dem game sein das ist doch cgi
mittlerweile ist es wirklich schwierig zu unterscheiden kann sich noch irgendjemand an
dies an diese rare nachlade animation aus battlefield hardline erinnern dass das ist
das ist real life hier es sieht halt einfach aus wie aus dem game dann sieht zum beispiel
auch an der uhr spiegelung und sowas wie lange geht das eigentlich noch eine jetzt ist vorbei
klar ja okay das war er war schon echt hier battlefield hardline real reloads was ist das
für die megakack auflösungen guck sowas die dienst die fand ich schon ganz cool das war da irgendwie
eins von 100 reloads oder so war so eine extra special reload animation aber was kommt man das
alpha 4 games video erstmal fertig über detaillierten waffen animationen für jede mögliche situation
dieser zweig der industrie hat sich in den letzten jahren so weit entwickelt dass ein auge für detailgetreuen realitäten
bei Schusswaffen längst die Regel und nicht mehr die Ausnahme ist.
Es ist etwas, was man als Spieler für selbstverständlich hält,
worauf man meist gar nicht mehr achtet, einfach weil man schon in so vielen Spielen so oft
nachgeladen hat. Man entfernt halt ein Magazin und packt ein neues rein,
who cares wie realistisch das aussieht. Grund genug also ein wenig Stil mit reinzubringen.
Wie wäre es mit so einem lässigen Wegwerfen des alten Magazins? So ein cooler Flick oder so?
Sicherheitshalber noch ein unnötig starker Slap hinterher? Bewegungen,
die 1 zu 1 aus Hollywood-Blockbustern stammen, weil Terminator ist halt ein cooler Film?
Oder doch gleich was komplett verrücktes? Animationen, bei denen der Realismus gelegentlich
etwas leiden muss, um dafür dem Spiel ein gutes Stück mehr Persönlichkeit zu bringen.
Und eines der besten Beispiele dafür ist wohl Black von 2006.
Was? Der buddelt da immer Games aus? Hab ich noch nie was von gehört. Kennt das jemand?
Ein Shooter, in dem die Waffe an sich im Vordergrund stehen sollte und man keinerlei
Zeit verschwenden wollte, um diesen Fokus deutlich zu machen. Slow-Mo-Waffen im Hauptmenü,
eine ausführliche Draw-Animation direkt zum Spielstart, Türen, die erst aufgeschossen
werden müssen, und die Waffe, die man nicht mehr auswählen kann, die man nicht mehr auswählen
kann, die man nicht mehr auswählen kann, die man nicht mehr auswählen kann.
Und jede Menge Explosionen überall. Ein Spiel mit realen Waffen, die aber nicht
genauso wie in echt aussehen. Eine AK lädt man z.B. nicht so nach und die Patronenhülsen
kommen sowieso auf der falschen Seite. Das ist an sich kein Fehler, wir sind ja nicht
bei Counter-Strike 1.6. Man dachte sich einfach nur, es sieht so interessant
aus. Hier haben wir ein Spiel, bei dem man sich Zeit lässt, bei dem Visiere erst aufgeplöppt werden,
in Magazine reingeguckt wird. Und allgemein wird jeder einzelne Schritt des Nachladens
möglichst gut und vor allem lang in Szene gesetzt, während die Animation innerhalb von Kämpfen etwas
abgekürzt wird. Es hat ein bisschen was von so einer Waffeninspektionstaste, Jahre bevor das
überhaupt ne Sache war, nur halt fürs Nachladen. Und dank der Tiefenschärfe bekommt man ja sowieso
nichts anderes.
Aber es braucht nicht gleich puren Gun-Porn für gute Animationen. Es geht auch anders.
Gunfire Reborn ist so ein Spiel, das ich über die letzten Monate besonders für seine großartigen
Animationen schätzen gelernt habe. Dass man einen coolen grünen Bird spielen kann, ist an sich nur ein netter Bonus. Dabei ist es nicht einmal technisch brillant animiert oder sowas, sondern einfach super befriedigend anzusehen.
Wie diese Karten sind, ist der Anlass für einen neuen Game Boy. Das ist ein sehr tolles Spiel, aber ich würde es gerne mal wieder probieren.
Aufgeklappt wird sich die kammer immer noch etwas mit dreht und unser grobschlechtiger vogel sie mit druckartigen bewegung wieder füllt hat
So einen ganz bestimmten rhythmus dabei die man auch warum gibt es eigentlich game wo sich vögel gegenseitig abschießen
Okay, das ist eine frage weil es geht weil es geht wahrscheinlich
So wie bei diesem sturmgewehr jeder schritt
Wieso nicht genau rennt ist der letzte schritt auch ganz kurz gehalten wird bevor es weiter geht
Oder wie dieser armbrust hier in den clip raus wirft bevor man lässt sich den nächsten obendrupp slept
Oder wie snappy man seine kunai mit diesen typischen endposen wirkt
Oder wie man all die beweglichen parts dieser schogun shotgun hier mit der animation besonders betonen wollte
oder diese shotgun hier
Oder der da wie die kifferhexe
Es ist alles so super snappy und bis auf wenige
Ausnahmen und dieses schreckliche wir sind ein roguelite also gibt es perks damit alle animationen vorgespult werden ist das hat alles großartig
copyright games sagen für das hat leicht cartoon und nicht gerade realistisch aber mit einem fokus auf glaubt es wäre jetzt nicht so mein game
Das schießen kombiniert mit dem nachladen ergibt durch diese deutlichen bewegungen fast so eine art beat
Das macht nicht nur spaß anzugucken sondern macht es auch ein glück steht angeboten
Aber wann man wieder ballern kann
Allerdings ist es so ein aspekt der recht schwierig zu beschreiben ist wenn man ihn nicht gerade selbst ist ein gutes korps spiel okay
Also probiert man anhand der dumm shotgun zu verdeutlichen
Wie heißt das game ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
Ich glaube ich glaube wenn man nach roguelite
Bird sucht wird man das finden einer bewegung die trotz weniger frames nachvollziehbar ist gefolgt vom nächsten schuss
in der ganzen bewegung steckt etwas power etwas
entschlossenheit und das macht die vollständige
Rate viel leichter einschätzbar, als wenn
sie fehlen würde. Das stimmt.
Da hab ich noch nicht dran gedacht. Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt. Selbiges trifft
auf die Schrotflinte von Serious Sam. Am besten,
am besten, also was ich
halt mag, sind,
wenn die in Games noch zusätzlich
so eine zweite Ebene einbauen,
dass du Reload Cancels machen kannst
und sowas. Das finde ich cool. Das fand ich
beispielsweise in Bad Company 2 auch nice,
dass du die Shotgun Reload canceln konntest und
dann irgendwie 0,05 Sekunden
oder so schneller schießen.
Für die Zeit ist diese
furchtbar animiert.
Aber sie gibt durch diese deutliche
und durchgehende Bewegung ein sehr
gutes Gefühl für den Feuer. Bei Serious Sam
muss ich immer denken an
aaaaaaaaaaah
und damit auch den gesamten
Combat Flow wieder.
Als Kontrast hier mal die
Schrotflinte von Doom 2016.
Technisch zwar einwandfrei,
aber ohne Kraft dahinter, ohne Betonung
auf irgendwas. Eine Bewegung,
die man aus dem Augenwinkel kaum mitbekommt
und die völlig untergeht.
Die doppelläufige Schrotflinte
wird ebenso lustlos nachgefüllt
und dann ohne viel Schwung wieder zugeklappt.
Nicht unbedingt schlecht
und bei weitem nicht der schlimmste Fall.
Da hat er recht.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, ist mir auch aufgefallen,
weil das stimmt nicht.
Also nicht bewusst, ja.
Aber da ist schon was dran.
Aber für einen Secret Reload in der Battlefield 3
hat man dann doch lieber zu Doom 2 gegriffen.
Wobei hier aber sowieso
niemand an die Slickness von
Deep Rock Galactic rankommt.
Und was?
Oder hier.
Der gräbt immer Games aus.
What?
3. Etwas leblos.
Halo Reach.
Deutlich mehr Wumms hinter.
Was rein zufällig passt, weil sie in Reach
auch mehr Schaden macht.
Immerhin ist es auch Aufgabe der Animation,
ihr Gameplay-Informationen zu vermitteln.
Ein schwerer Rückstoß
oder eine unkontrollierbare Streuung
sollte im Idealfall auch in der
Animation erkennbar sein.
Ist etwas stark, soll es sich auch
stark anfühlen.
Nun hatten wir schon ein Spiel,
das Waffen als Persönlichkeit hat.
Eins, das Waffen mit Persönlichkeit hat.
Wie wäre es nun also noch mit Spielen,
bei denen die Waffen der Spielfigur
Persönlichkeit geben?
Much better.
Team Fortress 2 war glaube ich so eins,
der ersten Spiele damals, bei dem mir auffiel,
wie viel Charakter man in die Bewaffnung
von Figuren und der Handhabung
dieser Waffen stecken kann.
Ja, aber Hüte verkaufen, wichtig.
Wie seine Mini-Baby-Schrotflinte
durchladen muss.
Oder wie sich der Engineer und der Scout
die gleiche Pistole teilen, aber nur
letzterer all seine überschüssige Energie
ins Nachladen reinsteckt.
Ich finde, das hätte Valve beibehalten
sollen. CSGO hatte damals
in der Beta diese Desert Eagle Animation.
Das sorgte für einigen
Backlash, weil man eher sowas hier
gewohnt war. Aber anstatt sie
komplett zu verwerfen, hätte ich sie einfach
den CTs gegeben.
Einfach für diesen kleinen Unterschied in der Persönlichkeit.
Ah, ja.
Finde ich ein guter Punkt.
Overwatch wirft diese Team Fortress Idee
einige Jahre später wieder auf und bietet
einen Haufen bunter Leute,
deren Persönlichkeit du sogar aus deren Animationen
ablesen kannst.
Manche sind professionell und präzise
bei allem, was sie tun.
Andere sind locker und verspielt
oder auch einfach mal
komplett wahnsinnig mit einer Waffe, die
Er hätte das auch in einem Multiplayer-Match
filmen können, aber ich glaube, das hat er nicht gemacht,
weil da hätte er so geraged,
dass er das Video abgebrochen hätte.
Overwatch ist eines der
most rage-inducing
Games, die es so gibt.
Die kurz vorm
zerfallen ist. Dass deren
Charakterdesign dann sogar noch in so Kleinigkeiten
wie dem Kamerawackeln beim Laufen eingeflossen
ist, ist dann nur das finale
Das muss man, das muss man Blizzard
wirklich lassen. Also so vom Grundgedanken her ist
Overwatch wirklich ein geiles Game. Auch
die Helden sind so nice unterschiedlich gemacht.
Im Prinzip
ist ja, ich sag mal so, der
Heldencast ist das Ding von Overwatch
schlechthin. Die Maps sind jetzt nicht so der
Wahnsinn, ja.
Die Spielmodi sind jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Die Helden ist das, was Overwatch
ausmacht. Alles andere drumherum ist so
mittelmäßig, aber der
Heldencast und das Zusammenspiel ist halt
das, was Overwatch wirklich, zu Overwatch
macht.
Crysis 2 und 3 haben
andere Animationen fürs Nachladen,
je nachdem, in welchem Anzugsmodus man sich
gerade befindet. Eine normale,
eine vorsichtige,
wenn man im Tarnmodus rumschleicht.
Die News von Overwatch 2 hören sich bis jetzt sehr geil an.
Naja, so viele News gibt's ja nicht. Also
die einzigen Sachen, die ich jetzt nennenswert
mitbekommen hab, ist, dass es Fünfer
Teams jetzt nur noch gibt. Wobei
ich da echt meine Zweifel hab, ob das,
naja gut. Sie haben es mit
Balancing und guten Maps
auch nicht hinbekommen in Overwatch.
Also guten Spielmodi, guten Maps auch in Overwatch
einzig hinbekommen. Aber okay,
ähm, es gibt neuen Spielmodus,
2CP fliegt raus
und es sind nur noch 5
Leute in einem Team. Das ist so das Einzige, was
ich so in Overwatch 2 jetzt
multiplayer-technisch interessant finde. Ob das
Singleplayer oder diese Koop-Missionen irgendwie gut
werden, ich weiß nicht.
Ähm,
tja. Fünfer Teams
haben die wegen der langen DPS-Q-Time
gemacht. Irgendwie weit
bringt das was? Du meinst, weil du ein, weil du
einen Tank-Spieler weniger brauchst, ein volles
Team zu kriegen. Ob das, ob das
jetzt so einen Unterschied macht?
Ich mein, du hast jetzt kleinere Teams, aber immer noch gleich
viel DPS-Spieler. Die
Q-Time ist ja, glaube ich, eh nur sonderlich lang,
wenn du ab einem gewissen Level bist.
Also ich denke mal, ab Master Plus
wird es langsamer.
Zumindest hatte ich den Eindruck immer,
ähm, dass du ab da halt
deutlich länger wartest.
Und ab, und ab, äh,
GM Top 500 schon mal gar nicht.
Dann ist es vorbei. Was 10 Minuten,
in Platin. Na gut, das liegt eher daran, dass
wahrscheinlich kaum noch einer Overwatch spielt,
im Vergleich zu den Millionen, die sie da immer auf ihrer Homepage
schreiben. Äh, nur, dass die meisten
Tanks gar keinen, gar keinen Bock
auf den Change haben und Overwatch 2 erst gar
nicht ausprobieren. Äh, Green Zero, die werden
keine Chance haben. Der Multiplayer von
Overwatch 1 und Overwatch 2 wird exakt der
gleiche. Also, wenn Overwatch 2 rauskommt,
wird auch, äh, Overwatch 1
Fünfer-Teams haben und, äh, keine
Tanks mehr. Also, keine zwei
Tanks. Also, du kannst gar nicht sagen, ich spiele
weiter Overwatch 1. Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Ja, Twitch animierte
Emotes, da bin ich der Erste, der
eins hat, ja, sag ich euch.
Und noch eine deutlich
gröbere im Panzermodus.
Und das für alle Waffen.
Oder, du kannst auch zeigen, dass
die Spielfigur ein absoluter Amateur
ist, so wie in der Kampagne von Modern
Warfare 2019, weil
der Name noch nicht vergeben war. Und warum sollte man dann
Overwatch 2 kaufen? Naja, weil man
diese, vielleicht diese komischen Singleplayer-Dinger
spielen will und die bessere Grafik haben will.
Keine Ahnung.
Ey, die Kampagne von
Modern Warfare, die war so verschenkt.
Das hätten sie viel besser
machen können. Vom Ansatz her fand ich die
gar nicht schlecht, aber das war so verschenkt.
Ich muss sagen, ich fand auch die
Cold War Kampagne total verschenkt.
Die hatte, die hatte
so das letzte Drittel war richtig
nice und
auch so, wie ich es von der Black Ops Kampagne
erwarten würde. Der Rest war einfach nur
langweilig.
Hier sogar das Schießen an sich
spiegelt sehr gut erkennbar
wieder, dass sie keinerlei Kampferfahrung
hat. Oder wie
Ethan aus Resident Evil zwischen den Teilen
7 und 8 eine deutlich
professionellere Art bekommen hat, wie er mit Schusswaffen
umgeht. Er zum Beispiel die Pistole beim
Laufen nicht mehr hochhält, weil er aus
Plotgründen Waffentraining bekam.
Zumindest ist es
schneller als einhändig nachzuladen.
Oder du übertreibst es gleich andersrum
und machst ein Spiel voller Würfe
und Spins und
Flips und Patronen, die in die
Schrotflinte reingeworfen werden.
Das ist auch immer ganz unterhaltsam.
Wobei man es damit auch nicht zu
sehr übertreiben sollte, weil die
Novelty von Supercell immer nachlässt.
Das Remake fand ich echt nicht schlecht.
Die Reload Animations aus Battlefield wären zum Beispiel
weit weniger lustig und besonders,
wenn man sie jedes dritte Mal zu sehen bekommt.
Und es gibt noch
unzählige andere Beispiele, wie man es
macht oder eben nicht macht
oder was auch immer.
Eigentlich sollte das hier ein
Format über allerhand Unsinn werden
und nicht exklusiv über Nachladeanimation.
Aber das passiert halt.
Da setzt du dich an ein Follow-Up zu einem
kleinen, aber recht coolen Video
und plötzlich machst du ein ganzes Fass auf.
Animation ist ein
super faszinierendes Thema, bei dem
vermutlich eine Menge Leute unterschätzen,
wie wichtig es ist, damit sich ein Spiel
egal welcher Art, egal in welchem
Genre, überhaupt gut anfühlt.
Ja, das stimmt. Zumal das
auch so eine undefinierte Geschichte ist.
Ne? Also hast Games, da hast du
das Gefühl so nach dem Motto, ja, das ist nice,
das haut rein, das fühlt sich gut an.
Und du hast Spiele, die sehen auch geil aus, aber
irgendwas fehlt und man kann da oftmals nicht so
den Finger genau drauf legen und sagt
so, das ist es jetzt.
Da muss man schon ein bisschen Gedanken machen.
Dabei gibt es nicht immer nur gut und
schlecht oder richtig und falsch.
Jedes Spiel hat einen anderen Fokus,
einen anderen Stil und die
Animationen müssen immer zum jeweiligen Spiel
und vor allem in die Spiele. Ich muss sagen,
Valorant, da haben sie es mit den
Waffen, also meiner Meinung nach,
haben sie es ein bisschen verkackt.
Und zwar, die
Originalwaffen und so, ich meine, die sehen, finde ich,
relativ billig aus, aber ist alles okay.
Was ich halt null, überhaupt
nicht mag, ist, dass die Valorant Waffenskins
überhaupt nichts
mit den, oder
diese Epic Waffenskins überhaupt nichts
mit den ursprünglichen Waffen zu tun haben.
Genau, zum Beispiel diese Drachenskins,
das sieht einfach nur billig aus
und ist schweineteuer.
Die Animationen müssen immer zum jeweiligen
Spiel und vor allem in die
Spielregeln reinpassen.
Wenn etwas schnell sein muss, aufgrund von
Gameplay, muss es dementsprechend auch
animiert werden.
Darum bin ich auch immer so schnell butthurt, wenn es darum geht,
die Animationen einfach vorzuspulen.
Da hast du die Arbeit eines
Animateurs, der Frame für Frame
versucht, menschliche Bewegungen mit
Gewicht und allem nachzubauen
und irgendjemand beschleunigt es einfach.
Ganz egal, wie es danach aussieht.
Bis man irgendwann gar nicht mehr erkennen kann,
was überhaupt passieren soll.
Gott.
Hey Linkflor, du machst mich so traurig.
Oder man sich gleich völlig zum Affen macht.
Also ja, faszinierendes Thema.
Und ein gigantisches Thema.
Und dann haben wir bisher auch nur über Shooter
und auch nur über Waffenanimationen
in Shootern geredet.
Andere Genres
machen noch viel cooleren Stuff.
Und auch nicht ganz so coolen Stuff.
Es fing an, als Mittel zum Zweck,
um Gameplay-Informationen zu vermitteln.
Und es ist fantastisch, dass es
so viel mehr ist.
So viel Style hat.
Sogar etwas erzählen kann.
War das eben Ghosts?
War das Ghosts?
Kann ich da nur noch dunkel dran erinnern?
War das eben Ghosts?
Und Stuff.
Es fing an, als Mittel zum Zweck,
um Gameplay-Informationen zu vermitteln.
Und es ist fantastisch, dass es so viel mehr ist.
So viel...
Ja, das war Ghosts.
Ich hab's schon wieder fast verdrängt,
dass das Spiel überhaupt existiert hat.
Sogar etwas erzählen kann.
Und immer wieder
irgendetwas Besonderes ins Auge sticht.
So nicht, mein Freund.
Also, wenn es zwei Call of Duties gibt,
die ich komplett verdrängt hab,
dann ist es Ghosts und Advanced Warfare.
Weil ich ehrlich sagen muss,
ich mein Cold War auch.
Weil Cold War hab ich ja gar nicht mal richtig
versucht im Multiplayer.
Ich war schon so...
Stimmt, Infinite Warfare
hab ich mir gar nicht gekauft.
Du hast recht, das hab ich schon komplett vergessen.
Cold War hab ich im Multiplayer
nicht mal angefasst,
weil ich eh wusste, dass mich Skill-Based Matchmaking
wieder so krass abfacken wird,
dass ich mir das nicht geben kann.
Hidden Code, ich weiß nicht, ob das das Richtige
für den Stream ist hier.
Oh, das glaub ich
für heute zu Big Brain.
Für Aufwachen-Stream.
Da braucht man zu viel Hirn für das Video.
Doch, das ist gut.
Okay, wenn ihr das sagt, dann gucken wir uns das jetzt an.
TheRigRoll.com, das gibt's wirklich.
Stimmt, wir haben heute schon ordentlich
Subs gehabt, dann ist der IQ so weit
gestiegen, dass man sowas, glaub ich, sich jetzt angucken kann.
Wir sind alle
Big Brain, Max.
Also Chat, ich glaub euch ja viel, aber das nicht.
TheRigRoll.com
Clearly one of the best looking
websites on the planet, of course.
But let's actually look at the
source code, shall we?
Right-click, view source, and
what?
Warum? Moment, das muss ich ausprobieren.
Das muss ich ausprobieren, ob das stimmt.
Ich mach mal mein Linux4M an, sonst fang ich mir
doch den Keylogger ein oder sowas, man weiß
ja nie, man weiß ja nie.
Äh, Moment, das muss ich mir
jetzt angucken.
Wie heißt die Seite?
TheRigRoll.com
Alles klar.
Nur in Firefox. Haha, das wär nämlich das nächste,
was ich ausprobiert hätte. Wie sieht's in unterschiedlichen
Browsern aus? Das muss ich
jetzt ausprobieren.
Zack.
Firefox, ich weiß
nicht, die schaffen sich
eh selbst ab, so die letzten Jahre über.
Max, du weißt, dass der Streamer nur
so big brain ist wie sein Chat.
Der Streamer, also der Brain des Streamers
und Chats korreliert direkt
mit Subscriberanzahl.
Zumindest ist es bei mir
so. So, der Speedchamp, den kann ich
jetzt mal kurz wegmachen. Ach ja, hat jemand gefragt,
wie wir das machen? Wir werden das im
Stream weiter, weiter entwickeln.
Also, was war das hier?
TheRigRoll.com
Okay.
Wieso? Hat doch Source-Code.
RigRoll. Hat doch Source-Code.
So alles gut.
Ach, hier hat es keinen Source-Code.
Ah, die Developer-Tools darf man nicht aufmachen.
Okay, verstehe. Stimmt, warum hat das hier kein
Source? Interessant. Interessant.
Okay, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie man das, wie man das
machen kann. Aber schauen wir mal. Und im Chrome, im
Chrome ist es nicht so, oder was?
TheRigRoll.com
Äh.
Ja.
In Chrome gibt es das auch nicht.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
There's no code here?
Nothing? Nada?
How?
Well, let me explain.
Let me give you guys some context
here before we jump right in.
Dann.
Two months ago, I created my
blog, basically
redirects to a music video
composed with, you know, intricate
Yeah, okay, it's a RigRoll.
But, obviously, people were
very happy about it.
You know, like, very much flattered by my research blog.
I was having the fun of my day, right?
Until this dude, out of nowhere, comes with a PSA.
Instead of visiting the webpage and getting RigRolled,
he tries to uncover the code behind the website.
As you can see, this is the code.
I was just simply redirecting the page with a location assignment in JavaScript once the page was loaded.
Okay.
It's pretty simple.
Actually, too simple.
Anyone could have, you know, seen through it.
Easily.
So, I decided to make this a bit harder.
Gibt's da jetzt demnächst auch irgendwelche Wettbewerbe?
Ob Buscated, HTML, oder so?
Or hidden.
Okay, now check this out.
Well, it's not that obvious, right?
I'm including some Google Analytics code.
People ignore that, usually.
And then, I'm including this safe.js.
This simply console logs and reloads the page.
But what people don't know
is the fact that the script that's coming from Google
is actually an injected one.
Basically, it's a gadget.
I can inject some code.
And I would get back the same thing.
And people would think it's legit coming from Google and ignore it.
Generally speaking.
Then this injected code
would basically register a service worker,
which would act as a...
Ah, yes.
Verwendet eigentlich auch kaum jemand.
Ich habe übrigens überlegt,
ob wir unsere Speedtest-Seite
nicht mit Webworker machen sollten für Speedtest.
Whenever the page is loaded,
it would make a request
to fetch the safe.js script, right?
But this service worker...
Leute, das Video ist übelst langweilig.
Wollen wir uns das angucken?
Der Chat sagt zwar, das ist nicht schlecht,
aber ich finde es nicht sonderlich spannend.
Das ist auch so Resident Sleeper gemacht.
Nee.
Ich weiß nicht.
Skip. Okay. Excellent.
Skip.
Aufhören.
Ja.
Ich finde es auch zu langweilig.
Zumindest für heute Morgen
finde ich es zu langweilig.
Ich mache mal einen Bookmark.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das
irgendwann anders noch an.
Jetzt Valomat.
Nee.
Wir waren jetzt kein Valomat.
Wie lange bin ich denn schon on?
Guck mal.
Ich bin doch erst fast 2 Stunden on.
Home Assistant.
Nee.
Dann gucken wir uns das jetzt auch nicht an.
Dann wissen wir ja schon, wie es geht.
Das Strommessgerät hat er am Start.
Okay.
Ich will nur das Intro hören.
Hallo in diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Hallo in diesem Video nur ganz kurz gezeigt.
So geil.
Du weißt schon genau, was Sache ist.
Hallo in diesem Video nur ganz kurz gezeigt.
Hallo in diesem Video nur ganz kurz gezeigt,
wie wir mit unserem Home Assistant
auch mit Geräten kommunizieren.
Wann kommt das nächste Stellenanzeigenvideo?
Wahrscheinlich nach dem Battlefield-Video.
Also am 9.
Jetzt Battlefield-Video und streamen.
Und dann wahrscheinlich
irgendwann so am Wochenende
oder so.
Revolon18monat,
dankeschwü,
Hyper-Subscription,
Firefox89 Review.
Okay, das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Ich kann mein Review selbst.
Ich hab ihn jetzt ja eine Weile verwendet,
seit es da raus ist.
Also, mein Review zu Firefox89 ist,
das neue UI.
Ich zeig's euch mal.
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme mit,
aber,
warum ich der Meinung bin,
dass Firefox die letzten Jahre
irgendwie noch so die neuen machen kann,
die letzten Jahre über auch immer schlechter wird,
beziehungsweise, nee, schlechter, man kann,
schlechter kann man nicht sagen.
Aber Firefox vergisst, wer Firefox verwendet.
Firefox ist der Browser für die Hackermans, ja.
Der Mainstream, die 0815-Leute verwenden Chrome
und Firefox wird von Leuten benutzt,
die interessiert sind an, von Webentwicklung bis Add-on,
Customizable Browser, also die Leute,
die eigentlich keinen Easy-Mode-Browser wollen.
Und ich bin der Meinung, Firefox entwickelt schon
die letzten drei, vier Jahre komplett an ihrer Zielgruppe vorbei.
Firefox war immer schon der Hackerman-Browser.
Also, und vor allem seit Chrome groß ist,
ist Chrome der Mainstream-Browser
und Firefox der Hackerman-Browser.
Und gerade mit solchen Dingern hier,
ähm, wir tun so, wir tun so, als sind wir in ein,
als sind wir auf einem Tablet,
packt halt einfach nur ab.
Die müssen, die,
die können nicht Mainstream werden.
Wie sollen sie das machen?
Chrome, Chrome ist der Mainstream-Browser
und gerade weil das Ding von Google ist,
die können da nicht dagegen anstinken.
Hatten wir ja auch gesehen.
Die hatten eine ganz gute Verbreitung,
bevor Chrome rausgekommen ist.
Ähm, aber die waren, die waren weit davon entfernt,
quasi da irgendwie 90% oder so zu haben.
Auch davor schon.
Die waren nur ganz gut dabei.
Und ich weiß nicht, was sie jetzt für einen Anteil haben.
Die müssen gucken, wer ist ihre Zielgruppe?
Und meiner Meinung nach ist die Firefox-Zielgruppe
eben technikinteressierter.
Die mit ihrem Browser Dinger machen wollen,
die man so vielleicht im Chrome nicht machen kann.
Dürfen Feature-Requests ins Repo vom Speedchamp gemacht werden?
Kannst du machen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob wir es machen.
Aber du kannst es machen, ja.
Hast du schon über die Battlefield-6-Leaks gesprochen?
Ja, ich habe dazu gesagt, dass ich dazu nichts sagen darf,
weil ich es unterschrieben habe.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal kurz an,
was der zum Firefox 89 zu sagen hat.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich das ähnlich.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich schreibe meine Gedanken auf den letzten Firefox-89-Update.
Also, hier ist er.
Zuerst einmal, der heilige UI-Change ist Batman.
Ich meine, das ist eigentlich, wie bei so einem Spiel.
Das ist doch kaum, es ist doch gar keinen so großen Unterschied.
Das Einzige, was ich ein bisschen nervig finde, ist,
das mache ich mal kurz aus, dass es hier oben jetzt so,
also, äh, what the, ich will das ausblenden.
Okay, gut.
Ähm, dass es hier oben jetzt so fett ist, das nervt mich ein bisschen.
Das ist eindeutig größer, aber auch nicht viel größer.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also, pff, aber ansonsten hat sich doch kaum was getan.
Was hältst du vom Opera GX?
Habe ich nie ausprobiert.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Sehe ich ganz genauso.
Sehe ich genauso.
Ich, ich mag meistens UI-Changes auch nicht.
Es sei denn, ich sage, äh, ich will, dass das anders wird.
Aber dass die dann, dass der Hersteller gleichermaßen sagt,
ja, äh, wir machen es dann auch so, wie du haben willst,
kommt eigentlich nie vor.
Schon mal von Brave gehört.
Ja, aber wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht, wo, warum ich das nehmen sollte.
Also auf dem, auf dem Desktop, ne?
Auf dem, auf dem Smartphone mag das anders aussehen,
wobei auch da, ähm, gibt's ja auch andere Browser
mit eingebautem Ad, Ad-Filter und sowas.
Brauchen wir nicht unbedingt.
Ähm, and this is no exception.
So, I'm not really a fan of, like, the new way that the tabs are done.
Ähm, I'm not really a fan.
Ich benutze, auf Android benutze ich den hier als Browser.
Bromite.
Das ist ein Chrome, das ist ein Chrome ent, entgoogelt und mit Adblocker drinne.
Den finde ich einsch ganz nice.
Ich meine, das Logo sieht halt richtig painstampig aus,
sondern das hat irgendwie ein Dreijähriger in, in, in, in GIMP gemacht wahrscheinlich auch noch.
... I know that this is probably the main thing people are complaining about,
especially those who have smaller monitors. Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Nope. You know, I, I guess I'm kind of fortunate to have, like, a 27-inch Full-HD-Monitor,
but, yeah, even on something bigger like that, this is still noticeably bigger, like, this...
Ja, ich verstehe auch nicht, warum man das größer macht.
Warum geht das, jetzt mal, ich hab mal ne echt, echt ne blöde Frage.
Warum hat von den Browser-Herstellern, ist noch keiner auf die Idee gekommen, zu sagen,
wir versuchen es hier oben mal irgendwie ein bisschen kleiner zu machen.
Ich meine, in, ich muss auch sagen, in, sogar in Chrome ist mir das Ganze schon so groß.
Warum, warum kann man nicht zum Beispiel sagen, nehmen wir jetzt mal den Firefox hier,
ich mach noch mal kurz die...
... die, äh, Bookmarks, okay, lassen wir's, lassen wir's mal so.
Warum kann man nicht zum Beispiel sagen, man macht die Adressleiste hier oben rein?
Weil, die Adressleiste ist ja, die muss ja nicht so lang sein.
Man könnte ohne Probleme die Adressleiste hier oben reinmachen
und, ähm, expandieren, wenn man reinklickt, zum Beispiel, ja?
Frag mich, warum das noch keiner, warum da noch keiner, äh, ein bisschen mit experimentiert hat,
weil, umso mehr, äh, vertikalen Screen, äh, Screenspace man spart, umso besser.
Safari macht das, ja?
Gut, eins muss man sagen, Apple ist, was so Design-Sachen angeht, oftmals gar nicht verkehrt.
Der Apple hat aber auch das Problem, wenn's halt zackt, dann ziehen sie's trotzdem durch.
Ähm, das wär zum Beispiel so'n Ding, das, das versteh ich nicht, das könnte man, das könnte man auf jeden Fall machen.
Auch ansonsten könnte man das Ganze dynamischer machen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, kann man mittlerweile die Sachen in, in Firefox eigentlich,
äh, äh, gruppieren, wenn man sie irgendwie zusammenzieht?
Also, man könnte da richtig viele coole Sachen machen, wo ich mich immer frage, warum macht das eigentlich keiner?
Echt?
Echt nicht? Echt nicht?
Zack.
Hä?
Macht's doch.
Auch wenn mich das Ausfaden nervt.
Um ehrlich zu sein.
Hä? Macht's doch.
Hä?
Geh, das versteh ich nicht. Ich mach das immer mit F11, wie macht man das sonst?
Ist das so-called Pruning of redundant or less frequently used features from the user interface?
Ja, das sehe ich ja, das sehe ich ja im Prinzip, das sehe ich ja im Prinzip genauso.
Firefox sollte gucken, wer ist ihre Zielgruppe?
Und meiner Meinung nach sind es eindeutig die technikinteressierten Hackermans.
Und nicht die, und nicht, und nicht die Oma Mainstream-User.
...really means, we're going to...
Deswegen find ich es auch doof, dass Firefox immer der Meinung ist, sie müssen das so weiter, weiter runterdrehen und Sachen entfernen.
Das nervt mich.
Deswegen glaube ich auch, dass Firefox in ein paar Jahren noch unbedeutender ist, als jetzt schon.
Leider, weil ganz ehrlich, ein zweiter Browser neben Chrome, finde ich, ist eine wichtige Geschichte.
Und ich meine damit nicht einen Chrome Reskin.
Und jetzt kommt mir nicht mit Safari. Safari ist ja wirklich das Schlimmste überhaupt.
Gerade was das Unterstützen von modernen Technologien angeht. Safari ist der neue Internet Explorer. Ist einfach so.
Sie versuchen aber schon seit 4-5 Jahren mehr Mainstream zu werden und es klappt nicht.
Und es wird immer weniger, weil sie die Leute verkraulen, die sie eigentlich groß machen.
So ein bisschen wie bei Battlefield.
Was ist der Grund dafür, all das zu verändern, um es einfacher zu nutzen?
Diese Leute können nicht mal diese Teile anpassen.
Aber im Grunde genommen, die Leute, die Firefox tatsächlich verkauften und in diese Menüs gehen,
haben wahrscheinlich bereits die Zeit genommen, um zu lernen, wo alles in diesen Kontextmenüs ist.
Also müssen sie das jetzt wieder lernen und die Leute, die, wie ich gesagt habe, nichts verkauften,
müssen nichts lernen, weil sie das nicht mal zu Beginn benutzt haben.
Eine andere Sache, die wirklich furchtbar ist, das ist wahrscheinlich die größte furchtbare Sache,
die die Leute, die sich in dieser Situation befinden, nicht mehr nutzen können.
Ich finde, das ist so ruhig, irgendwie.
Ich zeige euch das Update.
Also wenn wir in die Sättigungen gehen, General.
Und wir gehen hier in die Netzwerks-Sättigungen.
Ach, ist das jetzt Default?
DNS über HTTPS.
Oder kann man das jetzt einschalten?
Firefox ermöglicht jetzt DNS über HTTPS von Default.
Ach.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Das war in Firefox, ich glaube, zumindest in den letzten paar Verlaufs,
aber das war etwas, das man selbst aufsetzen musste.
Nun, es gibt viele Probleme damit.
Zuerst einmal, es gibt viel bessere Methoden, um DNS-T Toughik zu encrypten,
DNS über TLS oder DOT ist was, was ich empfehlen würde,
wenn man wirklich DNS-T knife ist.
Der ganze Grund für den DoH und die Leute, die ihren DNS-Traffic encrypten wollen, ist,
Das heißt jetzt auch, wenn die Namensauflösung nicht geht,
Im Firefox, dann muss man sich nicht mehr damit befassen, was hat man in seinem Betriebssystem eingestellt, sondern was ist in diesem Setting hier drin.
Also ich kann beispielsweise in Windows oder in Linux oder wie auch immer Google DNS eingestellt haben, aber Firefox verwendet dann Cloudflare.
Okay, das ist gut zu wissen.
Blending your DNS-Traffic with normal HTTPS-Traffic.
The problem though is that this doesn't actually keep your ISP or really anybody from being able to track you.
It doesn't prevent hackers from being able to track you.
And it actually centralizes your DNS-Traffic to just a few resolvers.
And what would you know, Firefox is using Cloudflare as their default DNS-Resolver.
Ja, wahrscheinlich kriegen die Geld dafür.
And out there, even before this default crap was in place.
Wobei, nee, wahrscheinlich nicht, weil was haben die davon?
So now, here's what that's gonna do.
Cloudflare is now gonna be an even bigger target for hackers, because now you can redirect the traffic.
If everybody is using default Firefox, and I think Chrome is also doing this by default as well.
And this also gives Cloudflare more chances to censor the Internet, which they've done several times in the past.
Haben sie?
If you didn't know, Cloudflare itself is kind of responsible.
For maintaining large parts of the Internet.
They do DNS, they do CDN, you might have noticed.
DDoS-Protection machen sie.
That whenever Cloudflare has outages, it actually takes down large portions of the Internet.
So this just makes power, this makes their power over the Internet that much bigger.
Das ist jetzt aber schon ein bisschen an der Hahn herbeigezogen.
Ich meine, die meisten Leute haben halt ansonsten einfach 8888 Google-DNS drinstehen.
Und seinen normalen Provider-DNS zu benutzen, ist ja fast noch schlimmer.
And there's also issues with the Internet.
Wenn man mit DDoH von der Perspektive von Sys-Admins oder Network-Admins oder jemandem, der die Regeln für ihre gesamte Netzwerke erstellen möchte,
Actually, let me just go ahead and turn this off while I'm thinking about it.
There we go.
But yeah, anyone who wants to create rules for their entire network to like block ads, trackers and websites,
something that you might use a piehole to do, DDoH is going to screw that up.
Like, you know, let's say, for example, you have kids.
And...
Ja, also, das kann man jetzt aber schlecht dem Firefox-Update so anlasten, oder?
Das schalten wir halt aus.
...or whatever that connect to the Internet, but you want to block them from being able to access pornography or other...
So ein PC, was er meint, ist, glaube ich, eher nicht, dass dein ISP da mitschneiden kann, sondern dass Cloudflare jetzt halt alles bekommt.
Weil jeder standardmäßig Cloudflare verwendet.
Dann, nach dem Update.
Bada-bum-bing-dang-dings-dings-bums, Dankeschön, 12 Monate Hyper-Subscription hier.
Hyper-Subscriber!
Wird Max jetzt Reaction-Streamer?
Easy, easy content.
Warum ist das null?
Ja, okay, ist ja gut jetzt.
Ja, ich...
Okay, das ist...
Das Video hätte man sich jetzt echt sparen können.
Äh, impft, das wird dir keiner sagen können, bis es mal passiert ist.
Also, was er meint, ist, wenn jetzt alle, die standardmäßig Firefox installiert haben, über Cloudflare gehen,
und Cloudflare wird dann gehackermanned, dann hat man ganz viel Kontrolle oder so.
Ist ja letztendlich bei allem anderen auch so, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo da jetzt der große Nachteil ist.
Oder Vorteil, oder wie auch immer.
X-Hack-Y-X?
Ne, X-Hacky-X ist es wahrscheinlich.
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Ja.
Das wollte ich mir angucken, weil ich hab, ich hab, äh, Insurgency Sandstorm, ich hab mir das, glaub ich, schon vor drei Jahren oder so,
gekauft auf Steam, also schon vor einer ganzen Weile.
Ich hab das nie wirklich gespielt, außer die Trainingsmission.
Und eigentlich ist es ein Spiel, was ich echt cool find, wie von der Optik her, und was ich an Videos gesehen hab.
Aber ich glaub, das ist zu hardcore, da jetzt noch mit anzufangen.
Guck mal, was die Games dazu sagt.
Mal gucken, von wem das Video ist.
Der besten aktuellen Hardcore-Shooter heißt Insurgency Sandstorm.
Ist das Dimitri?
Ne, das, ach, ne, ach, das ist nicht Dimitri, das ist Dings hier.
Ja, der, der, ja, genau, der.
Also, zum ursprünglichen Release im Jahr 2018 hatte das Spiel noch mit einigen Problemen zu kämpfen.
Drei Jahre später ist Sandstorm dank kostenloser Updates ein deutlich besseres Erlebnis.
Böse Zeit also für ein aktuelles Testvideo.
Ja, dann zeig mal her.
Und das beginnt...
Das ist das Originale.
...einen kleinen Rückblick.
Insurgency Sandstorm.
Das ist nämlich der Nachfolger zum 2014 veröffentlichten...
Das war mal, das war mal irgendwie, ich glaub, das war ein Half-Life-Mod, ne?
Das, das ist, weil das, das Originale, Insurgency, also dieses, das Originale ist, ist, ist uralt.
Das war mal ein Half-Life-Mod oder sowas.
...das wiederum aus einem Mod für Half-Life 2 hervorgegangen war.
Ah, Half-Life 2-Mod, okay.
Für Sandstorm wechselten die Entwickler von New World Interactive allerdings von der damals schon etwas angestaubten alten Source-Engine auf die Unreal Engine 4.
Die Prämisse eines anspruchsvollen Multiplayer-Shooters mit viel Realismus und hohem taktischem Niveau blieb allerdings erhalten.
Habt ihr es gesehen? Das, das Code-Ravissier brachte trotzdem viele Probleme mit sich.
Mit der Unreal Engine 4 sah Insurgency Sandstorm zwar deutlich detaillierter aus, hatte aber zum ursprünglichen Release mit Performance-Problemen zu kämpfen.
Hinzu kamen reihenweise Bugs und Glitches.
Auch die Inhalte waren 2018 noch spärlich.
Besonders die lediglich sechs Level sorgten sehr schnell für Langeweile.
Allerdings versprachen die Entwickler damals, das Spiel nicht nur gesund zu patchen, sondern wie beim Vorgänger über Jahre neue Inhalte wie Maps...
Wie viele Spieler hatten das noch?
Das interessiert mich jetzt tatsächlich. Das musst du jetzt mal kurz nachgucken.
Äh, Insurgency Sandstorm Steam Stats.
Wie viele Spieler hatten das noch?
Ziemlich stable?
Ah, Moment, das sind nur sieben Tage.
Ja, relativ, relativ stable.
Kann man sich, kann man nix sagen.
Relativ stable, der ganze Kram hier.
Das hat so seine Nische, was die Leute spielen.
Mehr als wenn es anliegt.
Komm, komm, wir gucken grad mal so just for fun.
Leute, was meint ihr?
Wie viele Spieler der meistbesuchte Surfer hat?
Ich tipp mal auf drei.
Drei Spieler, drei Spieler auf dem meistbesuchten Surfer.
30, 0 W, Alter, niemals, niemals, Leute.
Niemals.
Fünf, fünf, okay.
Und wieder zu.
Dead Game, Alter, Dead Game.
Okay, schauen wir weiter.
Und dieses Versprechen wurde eingelöst.
2021 läuft Insurgency Sandstorm nicht nur stabil, flüssig und meistens fehlerfrei.
Die Inhalte wurden im Vergleich zum Launch mehr als verdoppelt.
13 Maps und über 50 unterschiedliche Waffen können die Spieler lange beschäftigen.
Hinzu kommen neue Spielvarianten wie die Nacht-Version der Maps.
Spiel ist einer von euch, lohnt sich das, sich das jetzt noch anzugucken?
Wie ein Hardcore-Modus für PvP-Spieler, der sich noch nachloser und realistischer spielt.
Die Maps sind um einiges größer als die Multiplayer-Level in Call of Duty,
aber bei weitem nicht so riesig wie in Militär-Simulationen wie Arma 3 oder Squad.
Alle Karten in Sandstorm haben ungefähr die gleiche Größe.
Na gut, Arma 3 ist ja auch riesig groß und man robbt nur rum.
Aber schauen wir uns mal die Grundlagen an.
Wir kämpfen in einem...
... im Nahostkriegsszenario auf Seiten von Sicherheitskräften oder Aufständischen.
Sandstürme oder Wetteränderungen generell, wie der Name des Spiels impliziert,
gibt es allerdings gar nicht, was ein bisschen merkwürdig ist.
Also wenn man schon Sandstorm im Namen träge, wäre ein Sandsturm im Spiel doch eigentlich...
Moment, Moment, das ist so eine Art Zombie-Modus, was da spielt, oder?
Mit Wellen, oder sind das echt Spieler?
...historisch, oder?
Naja, egal.
Vom Anspruch her platziert sich in Surgency...
...Sandstorm zwischen dem eher massentauglichen Call of Duty und der deutlich höheren Komplexität eines Squad.
Die vier verschiedenen PvP-Modi bieten Gameplay für 24 bis 28 Spieler.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Zielaufgaben, die jedes Team erfüllen muss.
Zum Beispiel rücken wir im Modus Frontline einmal quer über die großen Karten vor,
um in einer Art Tauziehen eine Reihe von Zielen vom Gegner einzunehmen.
Der versucht natürlich das Gleiche, weshalb es manchmal lange hin und her gehen kann,
bevor ein Team am Ende das Waffenlein...
...der Feinde zerstört und so die Runde gewinnt.
So ein bisschen war es wie Rush.
Dabei kommen auch Geländewagen mit montierten MGs zum Einsatz.
Mit denen fahren wir schnell über die Karte und nehmen Gegner mit dem großkalibrigen Geschütz...
Max, was meinst du ist...
...eine gezielte Rakete oder ein paar Granaten...
Max, was meinst du ist ein Gehalt als Software-Engineer drin mit einem Master und sieben Jahren Berufserfahrung?
Es kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an, in welcher Branche und in welcher Region.
...Machen diesen mobilen Geschütz aber schnell den Gar aus.
Allgemein sorgt die gute Balance im ganzen Spiel für ausgeglichene Gefechte und ist eine klare Stärke vom aktuellen Insurgency.
Ein anderer Modus heißt Push.
Hier rücken die Angreifer bis zum letzten Ziel vor, während die Verteidiger das verhindern sollen.
Da jedes Team nur begrenzte Wellen an Respawns hat, sind auch diese Gefechte sehr taktisch.
Denn manchmal haben wir nur noch eine Welle, um ein Ziel einzunehmen und dadurch neu wieder...
Ich find's gut, dass er mit Kaudra Visierspiel beste.
...was natürlich richtig spannende Momente erzeugen kann.
Das Besondere, in den meisten PvP-Modi nutzen wir Klassen.
Die haben je nach Fraktionen den Zugriff auf bestimmte Waffen.
Aufständische nutzen knarren russischer Bauart wie AKs oder ganz altes Gerät wie das M1 Garand.
Sicherheitskräfte setzen auf westliche Waffen wie M4 und Co.
Co. Die Klasse Sprengtechniker nutzt etwa Raketenwerfer gegen Fahrzeuge und Luftunterstützung.
Denn ja, auch Minigun-Helikopter, Artillerieschläge oder die berüchtigte Warthog-Barrage gibt es in
Sandstorm. Doch Vorsicht ist geboten, sonst trifft es wie hier auch die eigenen Teamkollegen.
Diese Feuerunterstützung kann aber nur von der Kommandantenklasse gerufen werden und das auch
nur, wenn ein Spieler mit Funkerklasse in der Nähe ist. Teamwork ist deshalb bei Insurgency
der Schlüssel zum Sieg. Etwas lockerer geht's da im Domination-Modus zu, der ähnlich wie der
Klasse- Spiel hat kaum jemand, nö, ich hab grad geguckt, die haben täglich immer noch so 3-4k
Spieler. Das ist mehr als viele andere Games haben. Teamwork Painschamp. Einfach Solo reinrushen und
alles bashen, easy. Keine Klassen und auch keine Feuerunterstützung. Dafür dürfen wir stets aus
allen Waffen, Granaten und Co. wählen, nur Raketenwerfer sind tabu. Fahrzeuge gibt es hier
auch nicht.
Auf verkleinerten Versionen der großen Maps sind in diesem Modus 3 feste Ziele verteilt,
die wir einnehmen und halten müssen, um Punkte zu machen. Wer also 2 oder sogar alle 3 Ziele
beherrscht, nähert sich rascher dem Sieg als ein Gegner, der nur einen oder gar keinen Punkt
kontrolliert. So rennen wir ständig von A nach B oder C, halten auch mal eine Weile einen Punkt,
um ihn vor Gegnern zu verteidigen, die ihn uns wegschnappen wollen. Außerdem ist hier der
sofortige Respawn aktiviert. Wie sieht's denn im Spiel aus? Ist das jetzt einfach nur Gameplay so von
ihm, wo er die schönen Szenen genommen hat oder läuft man da auch ein bisschen rum? Oder artet das
dann aus wie bei anderen, etwas realistischeren Games, wo einfach nur jeder in seiner Ecke sitzt?
Macht den Modus kurzweiliger, aber auch weniger taktisch als die anderen PvP-Modi. Im PvP-Modus
Firefight müssen wir 3 Ziele einnehmen, bevor der Gegner das schafft oder alle Feinde ausschalten.
Ich mein, für die Spieleranzahl sind's ein bisschen viele Spielmodi und Aufsplitten der
Playerbase, oder? Ich mein, wenn du 4000 Spieler nur hast oder 3-4.000 Spieler,
dann musst du gucken, dass du die irgendwie alle so in ähnliches, ähnliches Dings kriegst, ne?
Respawn gibt es hier nur, wenn ein Ziel eingenommen wird. Das erzeugt oft schwierige,
aber auch spannende Situationen, in denen wir deutlich unterlegen sind und unbedingt ein Ziel
sichern müssen. Nee, Bargains hab ich nicht mitgekriegt. Die Beheilung gibt es in Insurgency
Sandstorm gar nicht, dafür reichen wenige oder sogar nur ein Treffer, um das Zeitliche zu segnen.
Mit seinen PvP-Spielmodi deckt Sandstorm also schon ein solides Gameplay-Spektrum ab. Mal
sehr taktisch und vorsichtig, mal eher flott und actionlastig. Und dann gibt es ja auch noch die
PvE-Modi. Neben dem Kampf gegen menschliche Spieler geht's nämlich auf Wunsch auch kooperativ gegen
die KI ins Gefecht. In den zwei PvE-Modi müssen wir entweder zu Acht die 13 Maps von ziemlich
gefährlichen KI-Feinden zurückerobern, oder wir verteidigen feste Punkte gegen anstürmende Wellen
von Feinden. Das ist ja auch ein sehr guter Weg, wenn wir das so machen. Das ist ja auch ein sehr
guter Weg, wenn wir das so machen. Das ist ja auch ein sehr guter Weg, wenn wir das so machen. Beides erfordert
Teamplay und abrichtige Laune, weil es herausfordernd und intensiv alle wichtigen
Gameplay-Mechaniken des Spiels in sich vereint. Zwar agieren die Computergegner nicht immer schlau,
sind dafür aber zahlenmäßig überlegen, meistens ziemlich treffsicher und ebenfalls mit
Feuerunterstützung ausgestattet. Die PvE-Modi können wir auch als Nachtvarianten erleben.
Dann nutzen wir Restlichtverstärker oder
Taktik-Modi, die wir auch als Nachtvarianten erleben. Dann nutzen wir Restlichtverstärker oder
Taschenlampen und schrauben Infrarot-Laser-Pointer an unsere Waffen.
Nachts ist das Spiel meistens noch herausfordernder, weil Feinde schwerer
zu erkennen sind und die spärliche Beleuchtung manchmal unsere Nachtsichtgeräte stört.
Wie schon erwähnt, ist das Waffenarsenal von Insurgency Sandstorm in den letzten Jahren stark
gewachsen. Es gibt das ganze bekannte Arsenal aus Sturmgewehren, Sniper-Rifles, MGs, Schrotflinten
und so weiter.
Die detaillierten Modelle hinterlassen dabei einen authentischen Eindruck, während massig
Aufsätze aller Art verschiedene taktische Optionen eröffnen. Weniger Rückstoß, ein
zweistufiges Visier oder eine Schrotflinte als Unterlauf-Gadget – für jede Situation
gibt es die passende Ausrüstung.
Und die Schießereien hinterlassen wirklich Eindruck. Das liegt unter anderem am satten
Feedback, vom grellen Mündungsfeuer bis zum deutlichen Rückstoß. Auch die heftigen physikalischen
Auswirkungen der Schüsse auf getroffene Gegner stechen hervor. Treffer hinterlassen einen
Sprühnebel aus Blut oder man hört im Nahkampf die Schüsse dumpf einschlagen. Das ist manchmal
fast schon zu realistisch und erzeugt ein wirklich mulmiges Gefühl, etwa wenn ein Soldat
eine gefühlte Ewigkeit lang aus voller Lunge schreit, nachdem in ein Molotow-Gerät geschossen
hat.
Zusammen mit dem reduzierten UI erzeugt der Spieler manchmal geradezu beklemmende Emotionen.
Wer in solche Bilder zu authentisch ist, sollte eher einen Bogen um Insurgency machen.
In Sachen Waffenhandhabung, Bewegungsgeschwindigkeit und Realismusaktivität bewegt sich Insurgency
auf einem ähnlichen Modus wie vor Hell Let Loose oder Escape from Karkov. Waffenbeherrschung
will gelernt sein, weil der Rückstoß stark ist und kontrollierte Feuerstöße oft besser
funktionieren.
Trotzdem ist Sandstorm spürbar zugänglicher als Squad und Co, denn hier kommt ihr meist
auch ohne Sprachchat klar, selbst wenn ihr mit fremden Leuten spielt. Und ganz wichtig,
jeder Shooter-Spieler kann sich schnell in Sandstorm reinfuchsen, weil bekannte Genre-Regeln
gelten. Während man in Squad beispielsweise manchmal minutenlang joggen muss, um zur Kampfzone
zu kommen oder lauernd auf dem Boden liegen und lange abwarten muss, gibt es in Sandstorm
deutlich mehr Action. Das macht das Spiel kurzweilig, kompakt und auch zugänglich.
Und doch bleibt das Spiel ein Hardcore-Shooter, auch weil wir sehr verletzlich sind.
Kann man sich lehnen? Wahrscheinlich, ja, ja, kann man.
Ist nicht.
Aber man stirbt schon übelst schnell, ne?
...können auch mal langsam schleichen, dann wieder schnell und aggressiv vorstoßen, wenn
das Timing stimmt. Das macht Insurgency Sandstorm auch...
Weißt du zufällig, ob Dr. Kaboom noch mal vorhat, sich auf YouTube blicken zu lassen?
Ich glaube nicht.
...anspruchsvoller als Call of Duty. Ohne das ist es nicht möglich, sich zu verletzen.
Das macht Insurgency Sandstorm auch... Weißt du zufällig, ob Dr. Kaboom noch mal vorhat, sich auf YouTube blicken zu lassen? Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
...anspruchsvoller als Call of Duty. Ohne das ist es nicht möglich, sich zu verletzen.
Das macht Insurgency Sandstorm auch... Weißt du zufällig, ob das ist es nicht möglich, sich
zu verletzen? Ich glaube nicht.
...anspruchsvoller als Call of Duty. Ohne so komplex zu werden wie das erwähnte
Squat.
Aber damit ihr die Inhalte von Sandstorm voll ausschöpfen könnt, solltet ihr sowohl
PvP als auch PvE nicht abgeneigt sein. Denn beide Modi spielen sich grundverschieden,
ergänzen sich aber auch prima. Wer nur gegen die KI spielt und keine Lust auf PvP hat, kommt
wahrscheinlich etwas zu kurz. Der PvP-Modus ist hingegen integraler Bestandteil des Spiels
Und das spielerische Niveau in den Lobbys üblicherweise sehr hoch.
Okay, da muss man sich erstmal den Arsch abtryharden, dass man da ein paar gute Runden hinkriegt.
Auf PvP und auch ein bisschen Geduld zum Einüben mitbringen, dann kann euch Insurgency Sandstorm lange fesseln und immer wieder vor Herausforderungen stellen.
Lasst euch dabei nicht von den teils niedrigen Spielerzahlen abschrecken.
Lediglich zwischen 2000 und 3000 gleichzeitig aktive Spieler aus...
Das ist gar nicht so wenig.
Allerdings hatten wir aktuell nie Probleme beim Matchmaking.
Zumindest zu üblichen Spielzeiten.
Morgens um 5 Uhr können manche Modi schon mal keine Spieler mehr haben.
Es gibt einen Kanal, da hat der Typ dieselbe Stimme wie Dr. Kaboom. Zeig mal her.
...tagsüber und bis in die Nacht gibt es stets volle Lobbys.
Das Matchmaking geht übrigens schnell. Wartezeiten von mehr als einer Minute sind die große Ausnahme.
Und die Entwickler sind auch...
Moment.
Weiße Scheiße?
Es gibt wirklich einen Skin, der Weiße Scheiße heißt?
Ach, hat er selber so gespeichert? Ah, man kann das selbst so nennen oder was?
Und die Entwickler sind auch noch längst nicht fertig mit dem Spiel.
Kürzlich am 18. Mai ist die neue Operation Exodus erschienen und die hat wie gewohnt eine große neue Map namens Citadel im Gepäck.
Im Survival-Modus treten wir im Team an und haben Anerkennung.
Wir haben anfangs nur eine Pistole, damit müssen wir quer durch die Level vorrücken, zufällige Punkte einnehmen und werden dafür mit Waffen belohnt.
Das ist richtig anspruchsvoll, denn andauernd stürmen KI-Feinde von allen Seiten auf uns ein.
Am Ende winkt der Sieg, wenn wir an einem Helikopter ankommen und das Kriegsgebiet verlassen.
Insurgency Sandstorm wird also noch größer und vielseitiger.
Die hohe Qualität der Inhalte bleibt bestehen, die Maps und Waffen wirken sauber ausgearbeitet und auf den ersten Blick weit geändert.
Die Waffen sind immer wieder gut ausbalanciert.
Lediglich der neue Revolver, der als Taschensniper verwendet werden kann, ist potenziell zu mächtig.
Auch technisch hat sich einiges getan.
Früher litten neue Karten zu Beginn gerne mal unter Framerate-Einbrüchen.
Auf Citadel konnten wir jetzt aber keine Rückgabe feststellen.
Die Entwickler scheinen also die Unreal Engine 4 inzwischen gut im Griff zu haben.
Spielt ihr selbst aktiv?
Stimmt ihr uns zu, dass sich Insurgency Sandstorm zu einem Super-Taktik-Modus bringt?
Oder habt ihr euch schon mal einen Taktik-Shooter entwickelt?
Ich würde es echt mal gerne ausprobieren.
Zwar nicht im Stream, aber einfach mal so.
Das ist ein Game, das ich mir eigentlich nicht umsonst gekauft habe.
Ich wollte es die ganze Zeit schon mal ein bisschen spielen.
Weil ich halt einfach Games brauche.
Cute Squad. Ja, können wir machen.
Können wir machen, aber dann muss ich mir erst mal ein bisschen das Spiel angucken.
Weil ich kann Games nicht lernen, wenn ich mit Leuten im Squad spiele.
Das geht erst, wenn ich das Game schon ein bisschen kann.
Und Leute, ich bin immer noch müde, obwohl das eigentlich Aufwachen-Stream ist.
Guck mal, ich bin jetzt ziemlich genau zwei Stunden aufwachen.
Und ich bin immer noch halb am einpennen.
Das gibt es doch nicht.
Resident Sleeper.
Guck mal, ich kriege nur noch solche Videos jetzt empfohlen.
Weil ich mir zu viel davon angeguckt habe.
Nach was soll ich suchen?
Mach mal den Typ an, der wie Kaboom klingt.
Was?
I.B.Sauer.
Okay, das ist schon mal nicht Kaboom.
So viel kann ich sagen.
Der oder was?
Oder was?
Oder wie?
Welchen?
Das hier?
Schickt mal einen Link zu einem Video.
Hast du nicht mal eine Weile CSGO gespielt?
Doch, habe ich.
Aber spiele ich schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr.
Eisenfreak Dankeschön 18 Monate Hyper Subscriptions.
Exquisite.
Also Leute, wenn ihr wollt, dass ich das gucke, schickt mir mal einen Link zu dem Video, woraus ich anhöre wie Kaboom.
Dann mache ich es auf.
Aber wie gesagt, also jetzt wo ich das Bild gesehen habe, das ist er auf jeden Fall nicht.
So viel kann ich leaken, glaube ich.
Larsi hat es geschrieben.
Der ist das, wo?
Wo ist der Link?
Schickt einfach einen Link, Leute.
Okay, das da.
Okay.
Meine Zweifel, dass er sich anhört wie der Kaboom, aber...
Fuck, der hört sich echt an wie der Kaboom.
Nein, vom Dialekt her nicht, aber von der Stimmlage her auf jeden Fall.
Auf dem berühmten Buch, auf das man reagieren musste, das hat Higgs getan.
Ja, okay, die Stimmlage ist auf jeden Fall ähnlich.
Wie ich scherzhaft sage, am verlängerten Wochenende, dieses ISLM-Modell.
Im Grunde, das ist schon da, er hat es ja nur leicht...
Ja, das stimmt, die Stimmlage ist wirklich ähnlich.
Die Stimmlage ist wirklich ziemlich ähnlich.
Aber der Dialekt passt nicht ganz so.
Wie gesagt, so viel kann ich spoilern, da ist es nicht.
Mining Bitcoin on Gameboy.
Ja, das haben wir schon geguckt.
Da kam raus, du konntest auf dem Gameboy nicht sinnvoll minen.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ich kriege nur...
MonkaS.
Wenn ich will, dass ich jetzt auf einmal nur noch fünf Zuschauer habe,
dann mache ich jetzt in 41 Minuten ein Regex-Tutorial an.
Dann ist es vorbei.
Kommt der Kaboom auch aus Hessen wie ich?
Ja, gar nicht so weit weg von mir.
Das ist zu lang.
Komm, wir gucken jetzt das Auer-Video.
Der Auer.
Ganz, ganz komische Sache.
Ich bin gerade mittendrin in meinem RTX 3080 Ti Review.
Ganz komische Sache.
Also eigentlich wollte ich gerade starten, meine Benchmarks machen.
Aber immer, wenn ich das in meinen Grafikkartentest-Setup einbaue,
also es ist immer noch mit einem 10900K, der bei 5 GHz...
Bestes, bestes RAM habe ich auch.
Hauptsache RGB.
Grundlage für meine Grafikkartentests.
Es ist immer VGA Detection LED.
Also seht ihr das hier?
Was für ein Ding? VGA?
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Ich kann es mir nicht erklären.
VGA in 2021 Null.
3060 reingesteckt.
Ihr seht, bootet vollkommen problemlos.
Keine Ahnung, was mit diesem Teil hier los ist.
Jetzt wieder diese Karte zurückgesteckt.
Ich habe es jetzt einfach mal in den anderen PC-Express-Slot,
der zwar nicht voll angeboten ist, reingesteckt.
Immer noch VGA-Erkennung.
Da habe ich jetzt einfach mal das Setup gewechselt.
Maximus 13 Hero, also Z590.
Achso, es hat jemand gefragt, ob ich schon geimpft bin.
Nee, ich bin noch nicht geimpft.
Ich bin beim Impfzentrum angemeldet
und bei meinem Hausarzt angemeldet.
Bei einem anderen 10900K im Prinzip jetzt alles getauscht,
bis auf das Netzteil und den RAM.
Aber kann sehr eigentlich gut sein.
Typischer Corona-Haus.
Ja, schauen wir mal.
Erstmal der Föhn.
Oh, das hört sich nicht gut an.
Wirklich jetzt.
Da gibt es nur eins.
Erstmal flüssig Stickstoff auf die GPU reinstecken.
Dann geht es bestimmt.
Alles klar.
Oder kennt noch jemand von früher den Bleistift-Trick bei AMD-CPUs?
Moment, Leute.
Kennt das noch jemand?
AMD-CPU-Bleistift?
Ja.
Mal gucken, ob es da so Videos dazu gibt.
Da konnte man.
Oder mit Klebeband ging auch.
Jetzt sehe ich wirklich kein Video dazu.
Guck mal hier.
Oh, ein CPU. Nice.
Ähm.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Finde ich jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Einfach nur zur Sicherheit habe ich jetzt noch das Netzteil getauscht
gegen jetzt die Sonic-Netzteil.
Ich meine, es hat eigentlich keinen Sinn ergeben.
Aber ich wollte jetzt einfach sicher sein.
Ich habe jetzt alles getauscht.
Bis auf den RAM. Aber der RAM kann es niemals sein.
Sonst würde er nicht bei D6 hängen bleiben.
Und er bootet ja auch mit anderen Grafikern.
Famous last words.
Aber, ja.
RAM kriegt wirklich nicht sonderlich wahrscheinlich.
Aber man weiß ja letztendlich nie.
Das ergibt für mich keinen Sinn.
Die Katz weiß Bescheid.
Was tun sie da hinten?
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was hier los ist.
Also da auch nochmal die Bestätigung.
Ich habe jetzt mal auf eine kleine Grafikkarte umgebaut,
dass ich nicht den Strom ständig umstecken muss.
Aber hier problemlos erkannt.
Genau das gleiche Setup.
Damit funktioniert es sofort.
Der PCI Express Slot im Arsch.
Der Monitor.
So dumm es klingt, aber ich werde es probieren.
Das ergibt zwar keinen Sinn, aber wir werden sehen.
Anderer Monitor.
Ist wieder ein Acer Predator.
Aber 60 Hertz Modell, 4K, wie auch immer.
Moment, ist das der Monitor mit einem Lüfter drin?
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Diese Dinger von Acer, die gibt es mit Lüfter.
Einziger Monitor, den ich kenne, der einen Lüfter braucht.
... zur Verifizierung, mit dieser Karte funktioniert es.
Äh.
Okay, der PCI Express Slot kann es nicht sein.
Der gleiche geht beim anderen.
Aber jetzt geht doch wenigstens das Bild an.
Was?
Es bootet?
Ja, nice.
Hä?
Es gibt Sachen, die muss man nicht verstehen.
Karte zu dem Monitor inkompatibel?
So etwas habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Ich habe es gerade nochmal zurückgebaut auf den anderen Monitor.
Und es bleibt beim Booten hängen.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre der Monitor defekt.
Und ähm, dann kommt kein Bildsignal.
Sondern die Karte wird nicht erkannt,
wenn der andere Monitor angeschlossen ist.
Ja, es gibt Sachen die muss man nicht verstehen.
Ja, so würde ich das auch gucken jetzt.
Es gibt Sachen die muss man nicht verstehen.
Ja.
Es gibt auch Sachen die versteht man so nicht.
Mein Kühlschrank der brummt manchmal.
Und wenn ich ihn restart, also ich kann meinen Kühlschrank restarten,
dann brummt er nicht mehr.
Weiß auch nicht warum.
Aber Debugging bringt er da anscheinend weiter.
Kann ich ja nicht mit dem Review anfangen. Perfekt.
Das heutige Video wird unterstützt von Hetzner mit dem Dedicated Root Server AX41.
Hetzner betreibt seine Rechenzentren...
Oh, Hetzner-Setout. Beste, beste hier.
Ne, ne, ich hatte mal einen G-Sync-Monitor direkt vor dem Video.
Der hatte keinen Lüfter.
...für Privat- und Geschäftskunden in Deutschland und Finnland
und legt dabei großen Wert auf die aktuellsten...
Moment, Moment. Ich muss mir das Placement mal genauer angucken,
dass ich weiß, wie lang das ist.
Und da kann ich mir was merken.
Der ist Meister des Sellouts.
Pater O'Haley, Dankeschön für den 10-Monate-Sub.
Okay, 23 geht's los.
Das heutige Video wird unterstützt von Hetzner mit dem Dedicated Root Server AX41.
Ah, er macht Werbung für Dedicated Root Server.
Bei mir war es Hetzner Cloud.
Hetzner betreibt seine Rechenzentren für Privat- und Geschäftskunden
in Deutschland und Finnland und legt dabei großen Wert
auf die aktuellsten technischen Standards
und gleichzeitig auch den Fokus auf die Umwelt,
wie zum Beispiel durch Verwenden von 100% Ökostrom.
In Finnland.
Der AX41 ist das Einstiegsmodell der Dedicated Root Server
und ist standardmäßig mit dem Ryzen 5 3600 6-Kam-Prozessor,
64 GB RAM und 2 512 GB NVMe-SSDs ausgestattet.
Das komplette Rack-Design und speziell auch die Kühlung
sind komplett von Hetzner in Deutschland entwickelt
und bieten neben 24-7-Support eine schnelle Internetanbindung,
DDoS-Schutz und unbegrenzten Traffic.
Mehr findet ihr über den Link in der Beschreibung.
Okay, Fetch-Sekunden, Fetch-Sekunden.
Äh, ja, Consumer-Hardware finde ich jetzt persönlich nicht so schlimm.
Ist doch durchaus in Ordnung.
Was interessiert mich, worauf das läuft, solange es läuft?
Das ist ja gerade der Witz bei Cloud.
Du hast auch keine Ahnung, worauf deine Sache bei Amazon läuft.
Also ich habe gelesen, dass die 3080 Ti
mehr oder weniger so ein bisschen
weniger so schnell ist wie die 3090, ungefähr.
Das ist mein Setting, ist natürlich auch sichtbar,
dass die GPU hier minimal besser ist.
Die schwankt hier zwischen 1950 und 2050, 2040 Megahertz.
Das ist einfach deutlich besser als die 3090 von Gigabyte,
die ich hatte, die lag ca. 100 Megahertz niedriger.
Und das erklärt dann auch, dass die haben.
Ich wette mit euch, wenn Nvidia dem Bauer Testmuster schickt,
die schicken dem schon preselected Dinge, die sie schon preselected haben,
die schicken dem schon preselected Dinge,
die sich gut übertacken lassen, weil die genau wissen,
das Erste, was er ausprobiert, ist übertacken.
Die Mining Protection wurde getriggert, mein Knalli-Bär.
Hm, vielleicht.
Ihr seht von 69,59 FPS.
Wenn wir uns dann jetzt die Benchmark-Egegnisse anschauen,
dann seht ihr, die 3090 von Gigabyte mit Overclocking lag bei 66,78 FPS.
Also wir sind hier glatte 3 FPS über meiner übertakteten 3090.
Und damit für die 3080 Ti,
bei mir hier das Ranking ganz klar an.
An dieser Stelle übrigens herzlich willkommen zu diesem Video.
Das hatte ich ganz am Anfang ganz vergessen,
beziehungsweise ich war schon mitten im Testing
und wollte euch einfach mitnehmen bei meiner Fehlersuche,
weil das schon, das war schon ziemlich crazy.
Jetzt funktioniert aber alles.
Es war tatsächlich ein Monitor-Kompatibilitätsproblem.
Ich habe es auch jetzt nach der Treiber-Installation nochmal zurückgebaut und nochmal gecheckt.
Es hängt da immer.
Das ist total crazy.
Ich habe es auch Nvidia weitergegeben.
Mal schauen, ob die da eine Fehlerursache finden können.
Ich werde mich jetzt aufmachen und mal noch ein paar Gaming-Benchmarks machen.
Und dann sehen wir uns dann wieder.
Aber schon mal zur 3080 Ti.
Es ist irgendwie auch eine strange Karte.
Weil die 3080 Ti ist ja nur
minimal anders.
Doch, Google hat angeblich auch,
ich weiß nicht, ob die Desktop-Systeme haben,
aber die haben wohl auch keine teuren Server-Kisten mehr.
Und wie es bei Microsoft im RZ ist,
für ihr Azure-Kram, ehrlich gesagt,
keine Ahnung.
Weil es nur das Microsoft-Rechenzentrum
unter Wasser hat.
Es ist 12 GB, allerdings,
wenn wir die GPU an sich betrachten,
weniger CUDA-Cores auf der 3080 Ti.
Ja, wen juckt's?
Im Prinzip ist es eine 3090
mit der Hälfte vom Speicher.
Weil der Unterschied bei der GPU ist wirklich, wirklich klein.
Interessanterweise ist die GPU hier
trotzdem schneller. Zumindest mal in dem Benchmark-Test,
den wir gerade gemacht haben.
Na gut, er konnte es ja auch 100 MHz mehr übertacken.
Die 3080 Ti halten soll gegenüber der 3090.
Das wird auf dieses Pricing ankommen.
Was sollen die kosten?
Ich möchte die gar nicht ansprechen.
Wird eh teuer.
Weil das führt sowieso zu nichts.
Ich würde sagen,
die 3080 Ti trotzdem irgendwie eine strange Karte.
Weil der Kühler ist ja viel kleiner als bei der 3090.
Das heißt, die 3090 wird tendenziell
besser gekühlt.
Könnte man rein theoretisch besser übertacken.
Also jetzt nur mal über die Founders Edition gesprochen, logischerweise.
Weil hier haben wir quasi den kleinen Kühler
von der 3080,
während die 3090 deutlich größer ist.
Dementsprechend die auch mehr Abwärme
abführen könnte.
Das wird ganz darauf ankommen, was die Karte kostet.
Aber aktuell,
ist es sehr ähnlich zur 3090.
Zumindest mal in dem Bereich,
wo man den Speicher nicht ausnutzt,
wenn man unter 12 GB bleibt.
Schon krass, wie teuer High-End-Grafikkarten sind.
Was sagt ihr, 3080 Ti kostet 1200?
Okay.
Es ist schon hart, wie hoch die Preise für High-End-Karten
sind mittlerweile.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja letztens ein Video gemacht,
wo ich so über meinen ersten Gaming-Pizza...
1200, lul, weh.
1200!
Ein wahrer Schnapper hier,
wie es aussieht.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Jetzt habe ich voll vergessen.
Irgendwas wollte ich gerade sagen.
Es hat mich jetzt voll verwirrt hier.
Ich habe doch mit irgendwas angefangen gerade.
Ja, egal.
Aber das wirst du im Leben nicht kriegen.
1200, der Scheiß ist so teuer.
Ja, genau.
Also,
als ich damals meinen Gaming-PC gebaut habe,
den Pentium 2 400,
also meinen ersten richtig echten Gaming-PC,
der nur für Gaming gedacht war,
da habe ich mir eine TNT 1 gekauft.
Und die hat, glaube ich, 250 Schmack
oder so gekostet.
Wenn man sich mal überlegt,
ich meine, das war 1998,
also trotz Inflation und allem
kommst du da im Leben nicht
auf 1500 Euro.
Auf 2500 Euro.
Und die war damals dann auch
das High-Endigste vom High-Endigsten,
was du kriegen kannst.
Und 3090 ist Centerboard für Advanced Games.
Aber da muss man auch erst mal hinkommen.
Selbst mit 4K passiert das eigentlich so gut wie nie.
Aber ja, ich mache mich jetzt auf als Testing.
Trotzdem ist es range-incardig.
Bin jetzt so weit eigentlich erstmal durch
mit meiner 3080 Ti, was das Testing betrifft.
Und ihr seht jetzt, ich habe hier eine 3090 drin.
Das ist die, die ich damals getestet habe.
Und ich will jetzt einfach nur den
3080 Ti Pressetreiber
verifizieren, um zu schauen, ob
jetzt auch meine 3090 damit irgendwie gefühlt
schneller geworden ist.
besser, man kauft schon eine PS5, wenn
die Hardwarepreise so weitergehen.
War schon echt schnell. Ja, aber wir haben hier
62,9 FPS und damals
habe ich 62,86 FPS
damit gemessen, also eigentlich identisch.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, riesen Unterschied.
Und damit starten wir auch mit den Gaming-Benchmarks.
Erstmal Remnant von The Ashes 4K
Ultra, da ist die 3080
TI bei den 1% Low
FPS 4 FPS hinter der
3090. Es ist im Prinzip eine 3090,
macht keinen Unterschied. Wenn wir
auf 1440p switchen,
dann sehen wir auch, dass hier die
3080 TI nur minimal hinter der
3090 liegt, aber hier muss man generell sagen,
dass 3080, 3080 TI
und 3090 fast gleich auf sind. Alles ziemlich nah beieinander.
Ist da eine 1080 TI auch noch
dabei? Ne. Aber guck mal,
selbst, ich meine, selbst wenn
du davon ausgehst, dass meine 1080
TI noch einmal 10 FPS
weniger hat, das lohnt sich ja fast nicht, da was
Neues zu kaufen. Ich bin mir sicher, wenn man die alle
in ein System ballert, dann würde man da
keine... Oder selbst wenn es 20 FPS weniger sind.
Aus persönlichem Interesse, weil ich einfach immer noch...
Machst du die Settings ein bisschen runter?
PUBG 0W, Alter.
Ey, PUBG läuft ja richtig gut.
Ach, eSport Settings.
Okay, eSport Settings ist ja im Endeffekt
alles, alles, alles Low.
3080 TI
etwas vor der 3090
bei den Average FPS, dafür aber
etwas hinter der 3090 in den
1% Low. Interessanterweise
ist es immer noch so, dass PUBG mit etwas
niedrigeren Auflösungen mit AMD,
eigentlich etwas besser läuft.
Die 1080 TI, ich komme immer mehr zu dem
Schluss, die 1080 TI
war eigentlich zu schnell für die Zeit damals.
Ich meine, wir sind jetzt
drei oder vier Jahre, vier Jahre
später, ja, und
die Top-Grafikkarten sind
zwar schneller, aber jetzt nicht so, dass sich das
wahnsinnig lohnt. Dann lieber
SLI 1080 TI. Ne, ne, ne, ne,
auf keinen Fall. SLI ist immer kacke.
... mit maximalen Details und
Raytracing enabled und da ist die 3080
TI eigentlich identisch zur 3090.
Einen FPS in 1% Low
kann man quasi vernachlässigen.
Wenn wir zu 1440p switchen, ist die
3080 TI minimal langsamer,
4 FPS weniger im 1% Low
und ein FPS durchschnittlich weniger
im 1%. Im Prinzip macht es kaum einen Unterschied.
Also wenn ich,
dann werde ich so ungefähr
auf dem Niveau liegen mit der 1080 TI,
würde ich sagen, ja.
Das ist dann, sag mal so, das ist ein Drittel
langsamer wahrscheinlich. Ja gut, das ist jetzt
von Sean mit Raytracing, gehen wir
mal kurz zurück auf
die E-Sport-Settings.
Ja, sagen wir mal so, sagen wir einfach mal
ein Viertel, Drittel, Viertel langsamer.
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung. Auch da wäre ich sogar
das neue Battlefield ohne Probleme spielen können.
Und ihr kennt mich ja,
ich spiele den Kram eh immer in Low-Settings,
dass es besser läuft.
4 FPS, dafür aber etwas hinter der 3090
in den 1% Low.
Interessant, quasi vernachlässigen.
Wenn wir zu 1440p switchen, ist die
3080 TI minimal langsamer,
4 FPS weniger im 1% Low
und ein FPS durchschnittlich weniger
im Average.
Ja, die 3080 TI,
definitiv solide Karte.
Ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher, was der
Zweck dieser Karte sein soll, weil sie ist
eben von der Performance her wie eine 3090
mit weniger Speicher.
Also zumindest mal in den Tests, die ich
gemacht habe, ist die 3080 TI
im Prinzip identisch zur 3090.
Ein paar FPS hin oder her, das würde
niemand irgendwie feststellen können, wenn ihr
die Karte besser als die 3090 in euren Rechner einbaut.
Ihr könnt hier safe keinen Unterschied
feststellen zwischen den beiden. Kann man natürlich
erklären, dass man die Karte dann ein bisschen günstiger
machen kann, weil weniger
Speicher vorhanden ist.
Es muss weniger Speicher verbaut werden, ist
dementsprechend günstiger.
In der Theorie könnte diese Karte günstiger
in der Theorie verkauft werden.
Ob das dann der Fall ist?
Darüber reden wir lieber nicht drüber, aber rein
theoretisch ist es wahrscheinlich eine 3090
mit weniger Speicher, um sie somit vielleicht ein
bisschen günstiger zu machen oder mehr
Speicher zu haben, um mehr Karten bauen zu
können. Das wäre jetzt meine Mutmaßung.
Ansonsten Founders Edition Karte mir
persönlich gefallen die mir extrem gut.
Also das ist natürlich rein subjektiv,
designtechnisch, so wie die aufgebaut sind.
Die fühlen sich mega hochwertig an. Bin ich
immer ein sehr großer Fan von. Da macht Nvidia
wirklich eine sehr gute Arbeit. Wo ich nach wie
vor kein Fan von bin, ist dieser dämliche
Stromanschluss an der Seite. Hat mir noch nie
gefallen bei dieser Serie. Ist für mich absolut
unnötig. Mit diesem dämlichen Adapter war ich
noch nie Fan von. Ansonsten Gaming Technik.
Wie viel hat die 1008 Steady damals gekostet?
Ich weiß es nicht. Die habe ich von Nvidia
damals bekommen.
Sponsort. Und seitdem habe ich mir auch
keine neue Karte geholt, weil das Ding tut
einfach.
Taktraten gut im Overclocking. Kann man
nichts Negatives großartig drüber sagen.
Ist halt immer die Frage mit
Preisverfügbarkeit. Aber wissen wir nicht
mehr drüber sprechen. Alles klar. Damit
bedanke ich mich fürs Zuschauen. Wir sehen
uns beim nächsten Mal wieder. Ciao, ciao.
See you.
Der Acht, aua.
So, also Leute, eigentlich habe ich schon
Hunger. Habe ich mega Hunger jetzt. Ich bin
am überlegen, ob ich jetzt einfach was essen
gehe. Same. Ich habe ja schon Hunger. Ich habe
ja gesagt, ich habe schon Hunger, seit ich
angekommen bin. Aber du bleibst da. Nee, ich
gehe jetzt was essen. Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis dann. Macht's gut. Ich gehe jetzt was
futtern. Ich habe mega Hunger. Vielleicht bin
ich am Abend nochmal da. Bis dann. Ich komme
aber schnell. Haben wir jemanden zum hosten?
Keiner das brauchen würde. So wirklich. Alles klar.
Schön, dass so viele mit dabei gewesen sind. Bis
dann. Macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.